If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史即是如此”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您也可以为您生活中的历史爱好者赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”即可。本集由 Hive 赞助。英国曾以工业力量的强大推动了未来的革命。但现在，您可以利用 Hive 的力量，掌控并改变您自己的能源未来。Hive 充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并让您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。Hive 的恒温器让您能够
for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires SEG tariff.
只需动动手指、挑挑眉毛，就能调节家里的温度。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其精准地保持在您想要的温度。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让您的爱车可以在夜间安静地充电，在您休息时同步补能。Hive 将供暖、充电和太阳能集于一身，通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，带来一场静悄悄的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive 终于让您掌握了自己的能源。请前往 hivehome.com 了解更多信息，具体取决于勘测和适用性。Hive 应用程序兼容特定技术。出售剩余电力需要 SEG 费率。
Your physician in ordinary to the queen, entrusted with the well-being of the heir to the throne. Only you had reason to believe that these unfortunate, these whores, these traitors, destroyed your life's work. Below the skin of history are London's veins. These symbols, the mitre, the pentacle star, even someone as ignorant and degenerate as you can sense that they course
作为女王的御医，您肩负着王位继承人的健康重任。只有您有理由相信，这些不幸的女人，这些妓女，这些叛徒，毁了您毕生的心血。在历史的表象之下，是伦敦的脉络。这些符号，主教冠、五角星，即使是像您这样无知且堕落的人，也能感觉到它们流淌着
with energy and meaning, I am that meaning. I am that energy. One day, men will look back and say, I gave birth to the 20th century. Crikey. So that's Johnny Depp and Ian Home in the film From Hell, which was released in 2001. and our thanks to the studio for giving us that authentic audio recording. And From Hell is an adaptation of the comic book by Alan Moore and Eddie Campbell. So the first person speaking, played by Johnny Depp, was Inspector Frederick Abiline.
能量与意义，我就是那意义。我就是那能量。总有一天，人们会回首往事说，我孕育了 20 世纪。天哪。以上是约翰尼·德普和伊恩·霍姆在 2001 年上映的电影《来自地狱》（From Hell）中的片段。感谢制片方为我们提供这段真实的录音。《来自地狱》改编自艾伦·摩尔和埃迪·坎贝尔的漫画书。刚才说话的第一人由约翰尼·德普饰演，是弗雷德里克·阿伯林探长。
And he is confronting the man he now knows to be Jack the Ripper, who is not a poor labourer from the East End or a Polish Jew or an American cowboy or any of the other theories that were so popular in the newspapers in 1888. The second man speaking there, played by Ian Holm, was a man at the very height of the British establishment, a man who has masterminded a conspiracy to cover up a scandal that would have brought down the monarchy and perhaps the British Empire itself. Tom, you're a fan of that performance there? Do you think that was a good performance? Yeah, it's a huge fan, and particularly of Ian Holmes' black eyeballs, which he has by this point in the film. And he will come to a horribly sticky end. Maybe we shouldn't give away who he's playing.
他正在与他现在已知是“开膛手杰克”的男人对峙，那个人并非来自东区的贫穷劳工、波兰犹太人、美国牛仔，也不是 1888 年报纸上盛传的任何其他理论中的人物。刚才说话的第二个人由伊恩·霍姆饰演，他是英国建制派顶层的人物，策划了一场阴谋，旨在掩盖一桩本会推翻君主制甚至大英帝国本身的丑闻。汤姆，你是那段表演的粉丝吗？你觉得那是一场精彩的表演吗？是的，我是超级粉丝，尤其是伊恩·霍姆在电影中那个阶段那双黑色的眼球。他最终会落得一个极其悲惨的下场。也许我们不该剧透他演的是谁。
We shouldn't, but we will reveal in due course. And I think it kind of illustrates the way in which the story of Jack the Ripper is so sensational, so melodramatic that people want a solution that is as sensational and melodramatic as the crimes themselves. The idea that it could just have been some random psycho, and perhaps particularly a random psycho from the same streets as the victims, is not something that people really want to contemplate. They want someone who is spectacular, dramatic, preferably famous. And I guess that that explains, doesn't it, why ever since the Ripper seemingly vanished
我们不该剧透，但我们会在适当的时候揭晓。我认为这在某种程度上说明了“开膛手杰克”的故事为何如此耸人听闻、如此戏剧化，以至于人们想要一个与罪行本身一样耸人听闻、戏剧化的解决方案。那种认为凶手可能只是个随机的疯子，尤其是来自受害者所在街道的随机疯子，并不是人们真正愿意去思考的。他们想要一个壮观、戏剧性、最好是名人的人。我想这就解释了为什么自从开膛手在 1888 年 11 月米勒庭谋杀案后似乎凭空消失以来，
into thin air after the murder at Miller's court in November 1888, people persist in coming up with solutions. And, I mean, it has to be acknowledged that decades and decades have gone. Solutions and solutions have been presented, and no one yet has come up with anything that has been accepted as definitive, has it? No, not at all. And I think your point is about the search for meaning, for the solution to have a sort of deeper meaning, actually reminds me of the series we did about the murder of John F. Kennedy.
人们一直坚持寻找解决方案。我的意思是，必须承认，几十年过去了。人们提出了各种各样的解决方案，但至今还没有人提出一个被公认为定论的方案，对吧？是的，完全没有。我认为你关于寻找意义、寻找一个具有某种深层意义的解决方案的观点，实际上让我想起了我们之前做的关于约翰·肯尼迪遇刺案的系列节目。
So remember when we did that, we were saying, you know, for conspiracy theorists, the idea that somebody's so powerful could be shot and killed in an instant by a nobody. And it might not mean anything. There's no conspiracy behind it. It doesn't tell you something about the inner workings of American democracy or capitalism. That's unbelievably frustrating. You know, it feels like you're waiting for the end of a story and the end never comes. And so with The Ripper, people want it, I think. people love the idea that it has a suitable killer to match the melodrama of the moment
还记得我们做那个节目时说过的话吗？对于阴谋论者来说，一个如此有权势的人竟然会在瞬间被一个无名小卒枪杀，而且这可能毫无意义，背后没有阴谋，也不能说明美国民主或资本主义的内在运作机制，这种想法令人难以置信地沮丧。你知道，这感觉就像你在等待一个故事的结局，但结局永远不会到来。所以对于开膛手，我认为人们想要它。人们喜欢那种有一个与当时戏剧性时刻相匹配的合适凶手的想法，
and that that killer must tell us something about the anxieties of the age or the or the secret workings of Victorian Britain or whatever. Well, I think it does actually and we'll be revealing our own solutions at the end of this show. I mean, I think it does, but I don't think it's kind of about the operations of high society or anything like that. I'm just going to put that up front. But of course, the other contrast with the JFK assassination is that, I mean, people may dispute that it's Lee Harvey Oswald, but there is clearly a suspect who stands centrally and that I think most people would accept did do it. That's the difference. So to quote Philip Sugden, who we've been referring
而且那个凶手一定能告诉我们一些关于那个时代的焦虑，或者维多利亚时代英国的秘密运作机制等等。嗯，我认为确实如此，我们将在本集节目结束时揭晓我们自己的解决方案。我的意思是，我认为确实如此，但我并不认为这与上流社会的运作有关。我先声明这一点。但当然，与肯尼迪遇刺案的另一个对比是，人们可能会质疑凶手是否是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，但显然有一个处于核心地位的嫌疑人，而且我认为大多数人会接受是他干的。这就是区别。所以引用我们在这个系列中经常提到的菲利普·萨格登的话，
to a lot throughout this series, because his book, The Complete History of Jack the Ripper is really the definitive survey of the case. He writes about the quest for the identity of Jack the Ripper and he says just up front, where anything at all bearing upon the killer's identity has come to light, it has proved at best, inconclusive, at worst, downright fraudulent. In this context, those who hunt the Ripper are vaguely reminiscent of the Spanish conquistadores, those foolhardy adventurers of four centuries ago who, driven by shimmering viciousness of El Dorado, cut their way through steaming jungles or toiled across burning deserts to find at their journey's end, not the riches for which their souls longed, but clusters of
因为他的书《开膛手杰克全史》确实是该案件最权威的调查。他在谈到寻找开膛手杰克身份的探索时直言不讳地写道：凡是任何与凶手身份有关的线索浮出水面，结果证明最好的也不过是毫无定论，最坏的则是彻头彻尾的欺诈。在这种背景下，那些追捕开膛手的人让人隐约想起西班牙征服者，那些四个世纪前鲁莽的冒险家，被黄金国（El Dorado）闪烁的邪恶所驱使，在闷热的丛林中开辟道路，或在灼热的沙漠中跋涉，最终在旅程的终点发现的不是他们灵魂渴望的财富，而是一堆
dirt villages or desolate plains. It has to be said, Dominic. It doesn't stop him from going through the list of suspects. And it's not going to stop us, is it? No, and I can promise the listeners, you will not get dirt villages or desolate planes. You will get cities of shimmering gold at the end of this podcast. Because we will go through the suspects, won't we? We will discuss them one by one.
泥土村庄或荒凉平原。多米尼克，必须得说，这并没有阻止他列出嫌疑人名单。这也不会阻止我们，对吧？不，我可以向听众保证，你们在本播客的结尾不会得到泥土村庄或荒凉平原。你们会得到闪烁着金光的城市。因为我们会逐一审视嫌疑人，对吧？我们会逐一讨论他们。
We'll treat them, you know, with the respect that their cases deserve. We'll weigh them in the balance. And at the end, we will pronounce a definitive verdict. And I think after this episode, people will say case closed. It's dumb. Would you like to remind people of what it is we're investigating, the salient details of these extraordinary series of cases? So this is what people need to keep in their heads, right, as we go through the suspects.
我们会以他们的案件应有的尊重来对待他们。我们会权衡他们的嫌疑。最后，我们会给出一个明确的判决。我想在这一集之后，人们会说案件已结。太棒了。你想提醒大家我们正在调查的是什么吗？这一系列非凡案件的显著细节是什么？这就是大家在审视嫌疑人时需要记在脑子里的东西，对吧？
We're looking for somebody who killed and mutilated about five or six women. We can't be certain in the east end of London in a very short period of time, August, November, 1888. Now, to remind people, all the murder sites are in a very narrow area. they're within a square mile, one square mile of the East End and the city of London. So, as Suckton says in his brilliant book, the assumption surely must be, not least given the way the killer was able to escape and to evade witnesses and whatnot, to get away without being seen, and to move in the night when he killed two people,
我们正在寻找一个在很短的时间内（1888 年 8 月至 11 月）在伦敦东区杀害并肢解了大约五六名女性的人。我们无法确定具体人数。现在，提醒大家一下，所有的谋杀地点都在一个非常狭小的区域内。它们都在东区和伦敦金融城一平方英里的范围内。所以，正如萨格登在他那本出色的书中所说，假设肯定必须是——尤其是考虑到凶手能够逃脱、躲避目击者等等，能够在不被发现的情况下逃走，并且在杀害两人时，
to move so quickly between one location, another location, the assumption must be that he is a local man one way or another. Either he lives in the area or he knows the area extremely well. Or he's a specter or a phantom. Right. In other words, if you think, well, he lives in a palace some miles away, you've got a bit of explaining to do. Now, there are multiple witness reports. Let's assume that maybe some of these witness reports are of the wrong person or they're fabricated
在两个地点之间移动得如此之快——假设他一定是一个以某种方式与当地有关的人。要么他住在该地区，要么他非常了解该地区。或者他是一个幽灵或幻影。没错。换句话说，如果你认为他住在几英里外的宫殿里，那你得好好解释一下。现在，有多个目击者报告。让我们假设其中一些目击者报告可能认错了人，或者是编造的，
or whatever. Even if that's the case, there are still enough of them, I think, to have a rough idea of the kind of man who's been seen talking to some of the victims. A white man, average or below average height, in his late 20s or 30s, most people, not all, but most of them say he's kind of shabby, genteel. So he's, you know, he's not a laborer necessarily. He's not covered in the dirt of his trade, so he's not obviously identifiable. But he's not wearing a top hat and wearing an opera cloak and so on and so forth.
等等。即使是这样，我认为仍然有足够的报告让我们对那个被看到与一些受害者交谈的男人的形象有一个大致的了解。一个白人，身高平均或低于平均水平，20 多岁或 30 多岁，大多数人（并非全部）说他看起来有点落魄的绅士风度。所以他并不一定是个劳工。他身上没有沾满工作的污垢，所以他不是那种显而易见的身份。但他也没有戴着高礼帽、穿着歌剧斗篷等等。
He wears the dark clothes of a working man who perhaps is coming away from or going to a place of work. Yes. He's probably got a moustache. There's a lot of accounts that say he's got a moustache as so many people do. And there are multiple accounts that describe him as wearing either a peaked cap or hat or a deer stalker hat. So, I mean, another salient fact perhaps is the days of the week on which the murders take place. So Polly Nichols is murdered on a Friday. So that's the early hours of a Friday. Annie Chapman, early hours of a Saturday.
他穿着工人的深色衣服，也许是刚下班或正要去上班。是的。他可能留着胡子。有很多描述说他留着胡子，就像很多人一样。还有多个描述说他戴着尖顶帽、帽子或猎鹿帽。所以，另一个显著的事实也许是谋杀发生的星期几。波莉·尼科尔斯是在周五被谋杀的，那是周五的凌晨。安妮·查普曼是在周六的凌晨。
Liz Stride and Kate Eddo's early hours of a Sunday. Mary Jane Kelly early hours of a Friday, but that Friday is a bank holiday. And just to throw in Martha Tabram, the first victim, she's murdered on the Tuesday morning after a bank holiday. So all of those murders in some way are, you know, they are at a weekend or kind of adjacent to a bank holiday, which, which again perhaps suggests that this is a person in regular employment. Right, because you can't quit murders if you're at work, right? And not only that, the killer is striking generally between the hours of midnight and 6 o'clock in the morning. That would suggest that the killer is somebody who probably is not married, does not have children,
利兹·斯泰德和凯特·埃多斯是在周日的凌晨。玛丽·简·凯利是在周五的凌晨，但那个周五是银行假日。顺便提一下玛莎·塔布拉姆，第一个受害者，她是在银行假日后的周二早上被谋杀的。所以所有这些谋杀案在某种程度上都是在周末或临近银行假日发生的，这也许再次表明这是一个有固定工作的人。没错，因为如果你在上班，你就不能去杀人，对吧？不仅如此，凶手通常在午夜到凌晨 6 点之间作案。这表明凶手可能未婚，没有孩子，
or at least has some kind of arrangements that will allow him to go out and desert his wife and children overnight. Or has a job that requires him to walk through Whitechapel in the early hours of the morning or come back from a job? So one other thing, the police made multiple inquiries in the lodging houses and DOS houses in the streets surrounding the murder sites. And they didn't find a single man there who seemed to fit the bill. That would suggest that this man either lives with a family, so he could live with his parents, for example, or he lives in his own rented private lodgings. In other words, he's not another person living in the DOS houses because he would have been caught. Let's go to the killings. I think the killings undoubtedly show that the man has some degree of anatomical knowledge.
或者至少有某种安排，允许他晚上出门并抛下妻子和孩子。或者有一份工作要求他在凌晨穿过白教堂区，或者下班回家？还有一件事，警方在谋杀地点周围街道的寄宿公寓和廉价旅馆进行了多次询问。他们没有发现任何一个看起来符合条件的人。这表明此人要么与家人同住，例如与父母同住，要么住在自己租用的私人住所里。换句话说，他不是住在廉价旅馆里的人，因为那样他早就被抓住了。让我们谈谈杀戮。我认为杀戮无疑表明此人具有一定程度的解剖学知识。
So cutting out the organs and things and all of that. The cutting out the organs. I'm going to give myself away here. I don't think I would have the capability to cut out somebody's organs. I wouldn't know what I was looking for. I wouldn't know how to do it. He does. So he's familiar with a knife and how to use it and he's familiar with the innards of the human body, or of a body anyway.
比如切除器官之类的。切除器官。我在这里要暴露自己了。我不认为我有能力切除某人的器官。我不知道我在找什么。我不知道怎么做。他知道。所以他熟悉刀具以及如何使用它，并且他熟悉人体的内部结构，或者至少是尸体的内部结构。
And finally, I think we need to consider why the crimes ended when they did. I mean, this is a massive question, isn't it? We were actually talking about this with the team before we started recording. Why does he stop? Because if you've been escalating and beginning more and more of a kick from doing these terrible things, you're not just going to give it up. It's not unknown, is it? So there are examples of the Zodiac Killer. The Zodiac Killer is an example.
最后，我认为我们需要考虑为什么犯罪在那个时候停止了。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题，不是吗？在我们开始录音之前，我们实际上正在和团队讨论这个问题。他为什么停止了？因为如果你一直在升级，并且从做这些可怕的事情中获得了越来越多的快感，你不会就这样放弃。这并非闻所未闻，对吧？所以有黄道十二宫杀手的例子。黄道十二宫杀手就是一个例子。
There was the so-called Monster of Florence. There are big gaps and hiatuses. But it is very unusual. It's more likely that the killer would stop because he died. He might have taken his own life. He might have emigrated. He might have been imprisoned for some other crime. We just don't know.
还有所谓的“佛罗伦萨怪物”。中间有很大的间隔和中断。但这非常不寻常。凶手停止作案更有可能是因为他死了。他可能自杀了。他可能移民了。他可能因其他罪行被监禁。我们只是不知道。
And I think all the more so for the fact that if we include Martha Tabram in the list of the people that he murdered, the mutilations are of an escalating ferocity, which implies a kind of gathering frenzy. So that is also something to bear in mind. So, to the suspects, we are going to begin with the ones that we have labeled mad theories. So these are suspects that have been presented as kind of serious suggestions that we nevertheless think basically a lunatic. Go on then. So I'm going to begin with what I think is the single maddest theory of all. And it was proposed on the 24th of November 1888 in an edition of a magazine called The Advertiser by an unnamed antiquarian who, and I
而且我认为，如果我们把玛莎·塔布拉姆列入他谋杀的名单，肢解的残忍程度在不断升级，这暗示了一种聚集的狂热，这一点尤为重要。所以这也是需要记住的一点。那么，谈到嫌疑人，我们将从我们标记为“疯狂理论”的嫌疑人开始。这些嫌疑人被当作严肃的建议提出，但我们认为他们基本上是疯子。继续吧。那么我先从我认为最疯狂的一个理论开始。它是在 1888 年 11 月 24 日的一本名为《广告商》（The Advertiser）的杂志上由一位未具名的古董商提出的，他
quote, had been consulting an old historical manuscript. And he writes, it seems that there was an old monastery in the 16th century on the spot where Mitre Square is now situated. So Mitre Square is where Catherine Edos was murdered. As was not uncommon in those days, the morality of the monks was not of the highest order. And in addition to many other crimes, one of the fraternity put the finishing touches to his wickedness by murdering a woman whom he had smuggled into the monastery at the foot of the altar. A curse was pronounced on the spot, and it was on the same place where the altar used to stand that the unfortunate woman, Edoz, was murdered. The writer of the story asserted in his letter that there is a plan of the old monastery in the British Museum, which
引用说，他一直在查阅一份古老的历史手稿。他写道，似乎在 16 世纪，现在的米特广场（Mitre Square）所在地曾有一座古老的修道院。米特广场就是凯瑟琳·埃多斯被谋杀的地方。正如当时并不罕见的那样，僧侣们的道德水平并不高。除了许多其他罪行外，其中一名成员在祭坛脚下谋杀了他在修道院里私藏的一名妇女，从而为他的邪恶行径画上了句号。那个地方被诅咒了，而那个不幸的女人埃多斯就是在祭坛曾经矗立的地方被谋杀的。故事的作者在信中声称，大英博物馆里有一张古老修道院的平面图，
enables the spot to be accurately identified. So, Catherine Edoz was murdered by a curse that dates back to the Middle Ages. The obvious flaw in this theory is what about the other ones? There's no answer to that, is there? No, there's no answer. I mean, that's just, yeah, that's bonkers. That is bonkers. So I think we can dismiss that one out of hand. So that's those ghost of a monk or whatever, but what about people who weren't ghosts? So there are a lot of famous Victorians who end up being dragged into this story, aren't there? So tell us about some of those. Again, I think it's a kind of guiding assumption that Jack the Ripper is so famous. I mean, one of the most famous people who lived in 19th century Britain, that you want someone whose real life identity was kind of
可以准确地识别出那个地点。所以，凯瑟琳·埃多斯是被一个可以追溯到中世纪的诅咒所谋杀的。这个理论明显的缺陷是，那其他人呢？没有答案，对吧？不，没有答案。我的意思是，那简直是……太荒唐了。那太荒唐了。所以我认为我们可以直接驳回那个。所以那是僧侣的鬼魂之类的，但那些不是鬼魂的人呢？有很多著名的维多利亚时代人物最终被卷入了这个故事，不是吗？给我们讲讲其中一些人。同样，我认为这是一个指导性的假设，即开膛手杰克太出名了——我的意思是，他是 19 世纪英国最出名的人之一——以至于你想要一个现实生活中的身份与之相匹配的名人。
of a matching celebrity. Right. So these are some of the famous Victorians who have been identified as Jack the Ripper. So William Eweitt Gladstone. Gladstone. Three times prime minister. And the reason that he is fingered is because he was a great man for going out at night and rescuing prostitutes.
没错。所以这些是一些被认定为开膛手杰克的著名维多利亚时代人物。比如威廉·尤尔特·格莱斯顿。格莱斯顿。三任首相。他被指控的原因是他非常热衷于晚上出去拯救妓女。
That is basically the only reason for suspecting him. Yeah, he rescued prostitutes or he basically just talked to them about the Bible, didn't he? and then he flogged himself, but he didn't flog them or, and also he would, he must surely be one of the single most recognisable men in Britain in the late 1880s as well as he's about 140, isn't he? Unless he's disguised himself beneath a Deer Stalker cap and a dirty working man's coat. I feel like Gladstone is a man who would absolutely give himself away. I mean, he's so recognisable.
这基本上是怀疑他的唯一原因。是的，他拯救了妓女，或者他基本上只是和她们谈论圣经，不是吗？然后他鞭打自己，但他没有鞭打她们，而且，他肯定也是 19 世纪 80 年代末英国最容易辨认的人之一，他当时大约 140 岁了，不是吗？除非他戴着猎鹿帽和肮脏的工人外套伪装自己。我觉得格莱斯顿是一个绝对会暴露自己的人。我的意思是，他太容易辨认了。
So it's obviously not Gladstone. Then there's Lewis Carroll, author of Alison Wonderland and so on, who supposedly, you know, he love a kind of tricksy rhyme and a kind of anagram and things like that. And supposedly in his writings, there are anagrams in which he confesses to the murders. But I think this is very much on the Paul is Dead level of historical inquiry, you know, kind of playing Beatles, tracks backwards to prove Paul McCarty's dead or looking at his writings and just kind of coming up and stuff. I mean, anyone can do that. Yeah. I also don't see him as a man with a close knowledge of the back streets of the East End. Surely Lewis Carroll would massively stand out.
所以显然不是格莱斯顿。还有刘易斯·卡罗尔，《爱丽丝梦游仙境》的作者等等，据说他喜欢那种诡计多端的韵脚、变位词之类的东西。据说在他的著作中，有变位词承认了谋杀。但我认为这在历史调查层面上非常类似于“保罗已死”（Paul is Dead）的阴谋论，你知道，倒着播放披头士的唱片来证明保罗·麦卡特尼死了，或者看着他的著作然后胡乱解读。我的意思是，任何人都能做到。是的。我也不认为他是一个对东区后街有深入了解的人。刘易斯·卡罗尔肯定会非常显眼。
No, because he's in Oxford. He's a very kind of shy, retiring clerical person. It's like Charles Dodgson, like people are going to spot him at Marlough. Yeah. Then WG. Grace, the famous hearsuit cricketer, he's been proposed because he was a doctor. But also the most recognisable man in Britain at that point, because it was beard. And also, and this is going to be a bit of a theme of this episode, he's off playing cricket all the time. So he probably couldn't have done it. Lord Randolph Churchill, the father of Winston Churchill, and he is proposed because he basically went mad with syphilis.
不，因为他在牛津。他是一个非常害羞、内向的教士式人物。就像查尔斯·道奇森，人们会在马尔堡认出他来。是的。还有 WG·格雷斯，那位著名的多毛板球运动员，他被提议是因为他是一名医生。但同时也是当时英国最容易辨认的人，因为他的胡子。而且，这会成为本集的一个主题，他一直在打板球。所以他可能没时间作案。伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵，温斯顿·丘吉尔的父亲，他被提议是因为他基本上因为梅毒而疯了。
Which is true. Yeah, he did. Syphilis is quite a kind of, it plays quite a role in the theories that we're going to be looking at. The idea that you're driven mad by syphilis and you might have been given it by a prostitute and therefore you have a vendetta against prostitutes and you go out and kill them for that reason. But again, there's no... Again, a very recognisable, well-known man. and also famously well-dressed.
这是真的。是的，他确实疯了。梅毒在我们将要研究的理论中扮演了相当重要的角色。那种因为梅毒而发疯，并且可能被妓女传染，因此对妓女怀恨在心，然后出去杀害她们的想法。但同样，没有……同样是一个非常容易辨认、众所周知的男人。而且以穿着考究著称。
So he would stand out like, I mean, he would stick out like a massive sore thumb in Whitechaple. Talking about people who would stick out like a sore thumb, I think after the kind of the the ghost of the monk, I think the single most improbable person who's been suggested is Joseph Merrick, aka the elephant man, who had a distinctive appearance. I think it's fair to say. He would stand out, I think. But the reason he's been proposed that he was living in the London Hospital. in 1888. So he is on the location. He was a famously kind and gentle man.
所以他在白教堂区会像……我的意思是，他会像一个巨大的大拇指一样显眼。说到那些会像大拇指一样显眼的人，我认为在僧侣的鬼魂之后，我认为被提议的最不可能的人是约瑟夫·梅里克，又名“象人”，他有着独特的外貌。我认为可以公平地说，他会非常显眼。但他被提议的原因是他 1888 年住在伦敦医院。所以他在现场。他是一个以善良和温柔著称的人。
Yeah. He's a lovely bloke, right? He's a really, really lovely guy. He's not going to have done it. And then a real wild card, which takes us back to two episodes we've done before, history's greatest eunuchs and the assassination of Abraham Lincoln. And this is Boston Corbett. Oh, the guy who shot John Wilkes Booth. And he had, people may remember, he had castrated himself after being propositioned by a prostitute. He was so upset by this that he'd hacked his testicles off. And then in due course, he gets, you know, after he's killed Booth, he gets confined to an asylum in Kansas. And Dominic, when does he escape from that asylum, do you think? So he escaped in 1888? Oh, my God. Do you know what, Tom? Actually, the more I think about it,
是的。他是个可爱的人，对吧？他真的是一个非常非常可爱的人。他不可能做这种事。然后是一个真正的“外卡”，这让我们回到了我们之前做过的两集节目：历史上最伟大的太监和亚伯拉罕·林肯遇刺案。这就是波士顿·科比特。哦，那个枪杀约翰·威尔克斯·布斯的人。人们可能还记得，他在被一名妓女勾引后阉割了自己。他对此感到非常不安，以至于他把自己的睾丸割掉了。后来，在他杀死布斯之后，他被关进了堪萨斯州的一家精神病院。多米尼克，你认为他是什么时候从那家精神病院逃出来的？所以他在 1888 年逃跑了？哦，天哪。你知道吗，汤姆？实际上，我越想越觉得，
he's as mad as a hatter, literally, because he's been driven mad by the mercury in hats. he's got a history of violence because he has killed somebody he has a history of very unfortunate interactions with ladies of the night he's actually he looks an increasingly plausible suspect yes and you know nobody knows what happens to him once he's left the asylum so it's perfectly plausible yeah he could have crossed the atlantic across the atlantic and ended up in whitechapel however for that there is no evidence so i suspect that none of those people are guilty. But there is one final kind of the most famous, famous person
他简直疯得像个帽子匠，因为他被帽子里的汞毒害了。他有暴力史，因为他杀过人。他与夜店女郎有过非常不幸的互动。他实际上看起来越来越像一个可信的嫌疑人。是的，而且你知道，没人知道他离开精神病院后去了哪里，所以这完全说得通。是的，他可能跨越大西洋，最终来到了白教堂区。然而，对此没有任何证据。所以我怀疑这些人中没有一个是罪魁祸首。但还有最后一个人，最著名、最著名的人，
who has been accused of being Jack the Ripper. And this is the Prince Andrew of the House of Saxe Kerrug, isn't it? So this is Prince Albert Victor, the Duke of Clarence and Avondale. Now this is probably the suspect that most listeners not super familiar with the case will be looking forward to hearing about because in the popular imagination, I think it's the one that has kind of become most embedded.
被指控为开膛手杰克。这就是萨克森-科堡家族的安德鲁王子，对吧？所以这就是阿尔伯特·维克多王子，克拉伦斯和阿文代尔公爵。这可能是大多数对案件不太熟悉的听众最期待听到的嫌疑人，因为在公众想象中，我认为这是最根深蒂固的一个。
And the reason for that, I guess, it goes back to your point about people crave a very glamorous, well-known and meaningful candidate to sort of justify the excitement of the murders. Do you think also that in this case, it's kind of in a line of dissent from all that stuff we were talking in our previous episode about the kind of the moral panic around upper-class murderers going out into the West End? And there is no one more upper-class than a royal, right? Yeah, I definitely think so. He's the pleasingly populist candidate, isn't he? Because it would be satisfying for a lot of people to think that the royal family are corrupt and evil and all of this sort of stuff. So he's the grandson of Queen Victoria. He's the eldest son of the Prince of Wales, the future Edward the 7th. So he is second in line to the British throne. So he is, you know, he's an important person. He was born in 1864 and the reason that lots of people listening to this will not have heard of him and be thinking, well, why doesn't he? become king, is that he actually died in the great flu pandemic of 1892, so he never succeeded to the throne. He was known as Eddie, although he's Albert Victor, he's called Eddie by his family and friends. He was educated at home, then in the Navy, and then went to Trinity College, Cambridge. He's a sort of lean, foppish-looking man, quite chinless, sort of he has a dissolute
我想这可以追溯到你刚才提到的观点，即人们渴望一个非常迷人、知名且有意义的候选人来证明谋杀案的刺激性。你是否也认为，在这个案例中，它在某种程度上延续了我们上一集讨论的所有关于上流社会杀手进入西区所引发的道德恐慌？而且没有比皇室成员更上流的人了，对吧？是的，我绝对这么认为。他是令人满意的民粹主义候选人，不是吗？因为如果认为皇室是腐败、邪恶的，所有这些乱七八糟的事情，对很多人来说会很满足。所以他是维多利亚女王的孙子。他是威尔士亲王（未来的爱德华七世）的长子。所以他是英国王位的第二顺位继承人。所以他是一个重要人物。他出生于 1864 年，很多听众没听说过他，会想“为什么他没成为国王”，原因是他实际上死于 1892 年的大流感，所以他从未继承王位。他被称为“埃迪”，尽管他叫阿尔伯特·维克多，但他的家人和朋友都叫他埃迪。他在家接受教育，然后在海军服役，接着去了剑桥大学三一学院。他是一个瘦削、看起来有些浮夸的男人，下巴很平，有一种放荡的
appearance. Yeah, kind of drones club vibe. Very drones club. Yeah, he'd be throwing bread rolls at Bertie Worcester. And he's best known today, apart from the Ripper business, because he was involved, he was caught up in a scandal in the summer of 1889 about a male brothel in Cleveland Street. It was basically a gay brothel. One of the people who was a customer was his father's eckery, Lord Arthur Somerset. And the American newspapers said, not only did this guy Lord Arthur Somerset go, but Prince Eddie was also a customer. Now, the British ones didn't. say he was a customer for obvious reasons. And it's very unclear today whether the American papers were just making this up.
外表。是的，有一种“无人机俱乐部”（Drones Club）的感觉。非常像。是的，他会向伯蒂·伍斯特扔面包卷。除了开膛手事件外，他今天最出名的是因为他卷入了 1889 年夏天克利夫兰街的一家男妓院丑闻。那基本上是一家男同性恋妓院。其中一位顾客是他父亲的侍从，阿瑟·萨默塞特勋爵。美国报纸说，不仅阿瑟·萨默塞特勋爵去了，埃迪王子也是顾客。英国报纸出于显而易见的原因没有说他是顾客。今天很难说美国报纸是否只是在编造。
And actually, most recent biographers tend to be a bit skeptical. They say, you know, Prince Eddie was involved with loads of chorus girls. He was a massive ladies man. He did have a very dissolute lifestyle. But this stuff seems to be slightly the result of a moral panic. There obviously sweeps up Oscar Wild at the same time because this is part of the background to the Oscar Wild trial. Anyway, in 1892, Prince Eddie died at 28.
实际上，最近的大多数传记作者往往持怀疑态度。他们说，埃迪王子和很多合唱团女孩有染。他是一个超级花花公子。他确实过着非常放荡的生活。但这些事情似乎有点是道德恐慌的结果。这显然同时席卷了奥斯卡·王尔德，因为这是奥斯卡·王尔德审判的背景的一部分。总之，1892 年，埃迪王子在 28 岁时去世了。
There was a great outpouring of national grief. Gladstone, who you've mentioned, was very upset about. It said he would have been a great asset for a liberal government. But then in the 20th century, when you would think he'd been forgotten, biographers started to say, well, he was a total waste of space and a terrible man. And they would sort of say he was lazy and he was dissolute and he was feeble. And again, it's not clear how much of this is code for them basically, for homophobia, for them saying, oh, he was caught up in this gay scandal
全国上下陷入了巨大的悲痛。你提到的格莱斯顿对此非常难过。他说他本可以成为自由党政府的一笔巨大财富。但在 20 世纪，当你以为他已经被遗忘时，传记作者开始说，他是一个彻头彻尾的废物和一个可怕的人。他们会说他懒惰、放荡、软弱。同样，不清楚其中有多少是恐同的代号，是他们说“哦，他卷入了这起同性恋丑闻”
and maybe he was gay and blah, blah, blah, blah. Anyway, in 1970, a doctor called Dr. Thomas Stowell publishes an article in The Criminologist. And he says he's worked out the identity of the Ripper, and he identifies the Ripper purely as S. And he says, oh, S, he was the heir to power and wealth. His grandmother was very much the stern Victorian matriarch. His father, to whose title he was the heir,
也许他是同性恋等等。总之，1970 年，一位名叫托马斯·斯托尔的医生在《犯罪学家》（The Criminologist）杂志上发表了一篇文章。他说他已经查明了开膛手的身份，他将开膛手纯粹标识为“S”。他说，“S”，他是权力和财富的继承人。他的祖母是非常严厉的维多利亚时代女家长。他的父亲（他是其头衔的继承人）
was a gay cosmopolitan and did much to improve the status of England internationally. And everybody, of course, said, that's obvious who you mean. You're talking about this one particular family. George the Fifth. Right. Very good. George the Fifth is the least likely person ever to have been, Jack the Ripper. Although, love to stamp. And stamps will be featuring as well. Yes, there is the stamp, isn't there? So, but also, I mean, George the Fifth did have a must. He had a beard, though, didn't he? He was bearded. And also, he had an unusual way of creasing his trousers, which would have been identifiable to witness. is, right? He creased them at the sides. Okay, so the argument about Prince Eddie is that he's
是一位同性恋的世界主义者，为提高英国的国际地位做了很多工作。当然，每个人都说，你指的是谁显而易见。你指的是这个特定的家庭。乔治五世。没错。非常好。乔治五世是最不可能成为开膛手杰克的人。尽管他喜欢邮票。邮票也会出现。是的，有邮票，不是吗？但同时，我的意思是，乔治五世确实留着胡子。他留着胡子，不是吗？他留着胡子。而且，他有一种不寻常的折叠裤子的方式，这对于目击者来说是可以辨认的，对吧？他把裤子折在侧面。好吧，关于埃迪王子的论点是，他
dissolution, he's depraved, he contracted syphilis in the Caribbean. So that syphilis thing again. He's been driven mad because of the syphilis and he started killing prostitutes for revenge. He killed Elizabeth Stride and Catherine Eddows and at that point the royal family realised what he was up to and they put him in a mental hospital. He escaped. He killed Mary Jane Kelly. They locked him away and he died as a madman raving in a kind of locked chamber at Sandringham in 1892, the flu thing was not correct. So, Dominic, any problems with this theory? Loads of problems.
放荡、堕落，在加勒比海感染了梅毒。又是梅毒。他因为梅毒而发疯，开始为了报复而杀害妓女。他杀害了伊丽莎白·斯泰德和凯瑟琳·埃多斯，在那时，皇室意识到他在做什么，就把他关进了精神病院。他逃跑了。他杀害了玛丽·简·凯利。他们把他关起来，他于 1892 年在桑德灵厄姆的一个锁着的房间里像个疯子一样咆哮着死去，流感的事情是不正确的。所以，多米尼克，这个理论有什么问题吗？问题太多了。
So first of all, Stowell claimed that he got this information from the secret notes of the prince's doctor, Sir William Gull, a man will be hearing from later. But Dull died in 1890 before the prince, so how could he know how this story would have played out? Well, he could have been a Mason and have had supernatural knowledge of it. Right. Yes, he could, and we should be coming to this. Second point, I think a massive hurdle for the Prince Eddie theory.
首先，斯托尔声称他从王子的医生威廉·古尔爵士（我们稍后会听到这个名字）的秘密笔记中获得了这些信息。但古尔在 1890 年就去世了，比王子早，所以他怎么可能知道这个故事会如何发展？好吧，他可能是个共济会成员，拥有超自然的知识。没错。是的，他可能是，我们应该谈谈这个。第二点，我认为埃迪王子理论的一个巨大障碍。
the prince does not have a close working knowledge of the alleys of Whitechapel and he would stand out massively he's not a working man he's he's taller than the ripper descriptions he you know he's immediately identifiable his voice would give him away he's got a weak chin hasn't he no one has a weak chin in the east end no no no not in the east end finally i think another insuperable obstacle he has an unbreakable alibi for every murder. So the murder of Polly Nichols, he was in Yorkshire with Viscount Down.
王子对白教堂区的巷子没有深入的了解，而且他会非常显眼。他不是工人，他比开膛手的描述要高，他……他立刻就能被认出来，他的声音会出卖他，他下巴很弱，不是吗？东区没人有弱下巴。不，不，不，不是在东区。最后，我认为另一个不可逾越的障碍是，他有每一场谋杀案的不在场证明。所以波莉·尼科尔斯谋杀案时，他在约克郡和唐子爵在一起。
For Annie Chapman, he was at a cavalry barracks in York. You see, he's somebody whose every movement is recorded. He was in Scotland with Queen Victoria for the double murder of Elizabeth Stride and Cathenades. I suppose it's plausible, just that Queen Victoria might be lying and covering up for him, but it's highly unlikely. So what then happens is that in the 1970s, obviously this theory is rubbish, but then in the 1970s, it gets a twist. And I'm sorry to say, it gets the twist originally from the BBC.
安妮·查普曼谋杀案时，他在约克的骑兵营。你看，他的一举一动都被记录在案。在伊丽莎白·斯泰德和凯瑟琳·埃多斯的双重谋杀案中，他和维多利亚女王在苏格兰。我想维多利亚女王可能会撒谎并为他掩盖，这在某种程度上是合理的，但可能性极小。所以后来发生的事情是，在 20 世纪 70 年代，显然这个理论是垃圾，但在 20 世纪 70 年代，它出现了一个转折。我很遗憾地说，这个转折最初来自 BBC。
The BBC made a mad series in 1973 called Jack the Ripper. And it was hosted by the fictional detectives from the then popular series, Zed cars, who sort of were investigating the crimes. And in the final episode, they had an interview week called Joseph Gorman. And Joseph Gorman said, my real name really should be Joseph Sickert, because I'm the son of the artist, Walter Sickert, from the 1890s and 1900s. We'll hear more from him later. And Joseph Gorman said, there is a royal angle, but the true story is more complicated. Now, Tom, you've done a lot of digging on this, so maybe you should take over at this point. Yes. So this ends up being turned into perhaps the single most notorious book ever written about Jack the Ripper. And it was by a journalist called Stephen Knight, who's a very peculiar person. And it's called Jack the Ripper, the final solution. Bad sign. It's a very bad sign. Here is a summary of what Stephen Knight says and presents as being the final solution. So Prince Albert Victor, still very much on the scene. He is taught art by Walter Sickert, who,
BBC 在 1973 年制作了一个疯狂的系列剧，名为《开膛手杰克》。它由当时流行剧集《Z-Cars》中的虚构侦探主持，他们正在调查这些罪行。在最后一集中，他们采访了一个叫约瑟夫·戈尔曼的人。约瑟夫·戈尔曼说，我的真名其实应该是约瑟夫·西克特，因为我是 1890 年代和 1900 年代艺术家沃尔特·西克特的儿子。我们稍后会听到更多关于他的消息。约瑟夫·戈尔曼说，有一个皇室角度，但真实的故事更复杂。汤姆，你在这方面做了很多挖掘，所以也许你应该从这一点接手。是的。所以这最终变成了也许是关于开膛手杰克写得最臭名昭著的书。它是由一位名叫斯蒂芬·奈特的记者写的，他是一个非常古怪的人。书名叫《开膛手杰克：最终解决方案》。坏兆头。这是一个非常坏的兆头。以下是斯蒂芬·奈特所说并呈现为最终解决方案的摘要：阿尔伯特·维克多王子，仍然在现场。他由沃尔特·西克特教授艺术，后者
is a very, very significant painter, I mean, a properly significant painter. Sikert introduces the prince to one of his models, who is a Catholic working class girl called Annie Crook. And again, like Walter Zicker, Annie Crook did actually exist. She'd been born in 1862, and she died in 1920, and she lived in a sequence of workhouses and then asylums. And in From Hell, she is played by Joanna Page, who people in Britain will have seen Gavin and Stacey. She's Stacey.
是一位非常、非常重要的画家，我的意思是，一位真正重要的画家。西克特把王子介绍给了他的一位模特，那是一个名叫安妮·克鲁克的信奉天主教的工人阶级女孩。同样，像沃尔特·西克特一样，安妮·克鲁克确实存在过。她出生于 1862 年，死于 1920 年，她住过一系列济贫院，后来住进了精神病院。在《来自地狱》中，她由乔安娜·佩奇饰演，英国观众会在《加文和斯泰西》中看到她。她是斯泰西。
And she ends up in a very bad way, shaved and lobotomized in a cell. So very upsetting for Gavin to see Stacey ending up like that, I think. So Prince Albert Victor falls in love with Stacey, secretly marries her in 1885, and they have a daughter. And this is, there's a massive potential here for a concert. institutional crisis, because Annie Crook, as we've said, is Catholic, and under the Act of Settlement of 1701, anyone in the line of succession who marries a Catholic will immediately be excluded from inheriting the throne. And so Stephen Knight's proposition is that the government of Lord Salisbury is thrown into a panic by this and hits the panic button and tries
她最终下场很惨，被剃了头，在牢房里做了脑叶切除手术。所以我觉得加文看到斯泰西最终那样会非常难过。所以阿尔伯特·维克多王子爱上了斯泰西，于 1885 年秘密娶了她，他们生了一个女儿。这有巨大的潜在危机，因为安妮·克鲁克，正如我们所说，是天主教徒，根据 1701 年的《王位继承法》，任何王位继承人如果娶了天主教徒，将立即被排除在继承王位之外。所以斯蒂芬·奈特的提议是，索尔兹伯里勋爵的政府因此陷入恐慌，按下了恐慌按钮，试图
to hush it up. But there's a huge problem in this cover-up because Annie had a a friend at the wedding. And the name of this friend was Mary Jane Kelly. Oh my God. What a twist. And Mary Jane Kelly was friends with Polly Nichols, Annie Chapman and Elizabeth Stride, although not interestingly Catherine Eddos. And they team up to blackmail Lord Salisbury and the whole British government. And so Lord Salisbury then has no option but to invoke the full powers of the state and specifically to invoke the Freemasons. It's the deep state, isn't it? The Freemasons are running the deep state.
掩盖它。但在这个掩盖过程中有一个巨大的问题，因为安妮在婚礼上有一个朋友。这个朋友的名字叫玛丽·简·凯利。哦，天哪。多么大的转折。玛丽·简·凯利是波莉·尼科尔斯、安妮·查普曼和伊丽莎白·斯泰德的朋友，尽管有趣的是，她不是凯瑟琳·埃多斯的朋友。她们联手勒索索尔兹伯里勋爵和整个英国政府。所以索尔兹伯里勋爵别无选择，只能动用国家的所有权力，特别是动用共济会。这是“深层政府”，不是吗？共济会正在运行深层政府。
It's the deep state. So we've mentioned that Sir Charles Warren was a Freemason, the head of the Metropolitan Police. According to Stephen Knight, so too was Sir William Gull, who was the chief royal physician. And Sir William Gull goes out in a carriage and he murders them, each of these women, according to Masonic rituals, with the assistance of Sir Robert Anderson, the chief of the CID, who people may remember was always on holiday in Switzerland. So people might think that's potentially a slight issue. And they also, they murder Catherine Edos, and that's a case of mistaken identity.
这是深层政府。所以我们提到查尔斯·沃伦爵士是共济会成员，他是伦敦警察厅厅长。根据斯蒂芬·奈特的说法，威廉·古尔爵士也是，他是首席皇家医生。威廉·古尔爵士坐着马车出去，他谋杀了她们，每一个女人，根据共济会的仪式，在罗伯特·安德森爵士（CID 负责人，人们可能记得他总是在瑞士度假）的协助下。所以人们可能会认为这可能是一个小问题。而且他们还谋杀了凯瑟琳·埃多斯，那是一起认错人的案件。
Oh, yeah. Because she was a jolly person and would never have blackmailed the... She'd never have joined in a blackmail attempt against Lord Salsbury. And this book, kind of like Graham Hancock or Eric von Danikam. It was a huge success, and its impact was completely disproportionate. proportionate to the probability of its claims. And it inspired from Hell, the Alan Moore animated novel, which in turn inspired the Johnny Depp film, with which we opened this. And the sinister figure who is saying that, you know, he's created the 20th century is actually Sir William Gull, played by Ian Holm.
哦，是的。因为她是个快乐的人，绝不会勒索……她绝不会参与针对索尔兹伯里勋爵的勒索企图。这本书有点像格雷厄姆·汉考克或埃里希·冯·丹尼肯的作品。它取得了巨大的成功，其影响与其主张的可能性完全不成比例。它启发了艾伦·摩尔的动画小说《来自地狱》，而这部小说又启发了约翰尼·德普主演的电影，我们正是以这部电影开场的。那个说自己创造了20世纪的阴险人物，实际上是伊恩·霍姆饰演的威廉·古尔爵士。
Do you find it plausible, Tom? Okay. So there are a number of problems with this, a number of issues of this. Gull was not a Mason. Lord Salisbury wasn't a Mason. And when Knight went and asked the kind of, you know, the historian of the masons, were they? He said no. And Gull and Knight just ignored him. So we've said that Knight claims that Gull is going around the East End in a carriage, that he kidnaps each of the various women who are blackmailing Lord Salisbury. He dissects them in his carriage and then he throws the bodies out where they're then found. People who've been listening to our episodes will appreciate that this is. is impossible. How do you get a carriage into, you know, all these various courtyards or narrow alleys or whatever? Yeah. I mean, it's just not happening. And I think, as it were, the killer problem is that Sir William Gull had had a very serious stroke in 1887. He was incredibly obese and he was 71. And again, I mean, he's up there with the elephant man.
汤姆，你觉得这可信吗？好吧。这里面有很多问题，有很多争议。古尔不是共济会成员。索尔兹伯里勋爵也不是共济会成员。当奈特去询问共济会历史学家时，他们是吗？他说不是。而古尔和奈特直接无视了他。所以我们说过，奈特声称古尔坐着马车在东区转悠，绑架了勒索索尔兹伯里勋爵的几名妇女。他在马车里将她们解剖，然后把尸体扔出来，随后被发现。听过我们节目的听众会明白，这是不可能的。你怎么能把马车开进那些各种庭院或狭窄的小巷里呢？是的。我的意思是，这根本不可能发生。而且我认为，最致命的问题在于威廉·古尔爵士在1887年曾中风，病情非常严重。他极其肥胖，而且已经71岁了。再说一次，我的意思是，他和象人一样，根本不可能。
as I would say the person least likely to have been roaming the East End murdering prostitutes. I think that's a huge problem. And actually, Dominant, he's a very impressive man, isn't he? I mean, he's now probably chiefly remembered as, you know, a suspect for being Jack the Ripper. But actually, he was a very admirable man of science. And he made breakthroughs in Bright's disease and paraplegia and the study of anorexia, a word which incidentally was coined by James I, So people who heard my episode on James I will remember that.
正如我所说，他是一个最不可能在东区游荡并谋杀妓女的人。我认为这是一个巨大的问题。事实上，多米尼克，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，不是吗？我的意思是，他现在可能主要被记住为开膛手杰克的嫌疑人。但实际上，他是一位非常令人钦佩的科学家。他在布赖特氏病、截瘫和厌食症的研究方面取得了突破，顺便说一句，“厌食症”这个词是由詹姆斯一世创造的，听过我关于詹姆斯一世那一集的人应该会记得。
And I think it's a great shame that he's ended up introduced in this way. If you had said to Sir William Gunn, and indeed anybody who knew him, he will be mainly remembered in more than 100 years' time as a suspect in the Jack the Ripper case. I mean, they would just have laughed at you because it would just have seemed so absolutely ludicrous. I think he would have been very upset. I don't think he would have been upset, yeah. But Dominant, you said that Walter Sickett, the artist, that he is. a further suspect, isn't he? So this is the kind of the next twist in this particular riff. Yes. So obviously Sir William Gull is a ridiculous candidate, but the Royal Conspiracy Theory,
我认为他最终以这种方式被介绍给世人是非常遗憾的。如果你对威廉·古尔爵士，甚至任何认识他的人说，一百多年后他主要会被记住为开膛手杰克案的嫌疑人。我的意思是，他们只会嘲笑你，因为这看起来太荒谬了。我想他会非常难过的。我不认为他会难过，是的。但是多米尼克，你说艺术家沃尔特·西克特是另一个嫌疑人，对吧？所以这是这个特定谜团的下一个转折点。是的。所以很明显，威廉·古尔爵士是一个荒谬的候选人，但皇室阴谋论，
or versions of this conspiracy theory will not die. And in the, some versions of the Girl conspiracy theory, the artist, Sickett, is part of the conspiracy. And actually, he's now taken centre stage for some sort of riparologists. So let's look at him. Sikit was born in Germany. He's a brilliant artist. His peak is probably the 1900s and 1910s, and he's a kind of post-impressionist. So he's a key figure in the transition from impressionism to artistic modernism. Now, this is an old theory, relatively old, because Sicket was first proposed in 1959 by a guy called Donald McCormick, who wrote kind of books about spy stories and murder mysteries and stuff like this.
或者说这个阴谋论的各种版本是不会消亡的。在古尔阴谋论的某些版本中，艺术家西克特是阴谋的一部分。事实上，他现在已经成为一些“开膛手研究者”关注的焦点。所以让我们来看看他。西克特出生于德国。他是一位杰出的艺术家。他的巅峰时期可能是在1900年代和1910年代，他是一位后印象派画家。所以他是从印象派向艺术现代主义过渡的关键人物。现在，这是一个旧理论，相对较旧，因为西克特在1959年首次被一个叫唐纳德·麦考密克的人提出，他写过关于间谍故事、谋杀悬疑之类的书。
And it's been taken up in recent years, I have to say, with tremendous gusto, by the crime novelist Patricia Cornwell. So she's gone to the lengths of buying 30 sicket paintings, and she's written two books about it. And bizarrely, she's been accused of destroying a sick at painting, hasn't she, as part of her research. But she denies this. I have to say her novels are brilliant. I love them. K. Skarpetta. Yeah, I've never read them.
而且近年来，我必须说，犯罪小说家帕特里夏·康薇尔以极大的热情采纳了这一理论。所以她甚至买下了30幅西克特的画作，并为此写了两本书。奇怪的是，她被指控在研究过程中毁坏了一幅西克特的画，不是吗？但她否认了这一点。我必须说她的小说很精彩。我喜欢它们。K·斯卡佩塔。是的，我从来没读过。
Does she not share a publisher with you, Tom? She does, but that's incidental. They are tremendous novels. But I do think on this occasion, she is slightly barking up the wrong tree. But anyway, Dominic, tell us about the... Well, let's see. Let's see, right? So, Sickett is born in 1860.
汤姆，她不是和你是同一个出版商吗？她是，但这只是巧合。它们是非常棒的小说。但我确实认为在这次事件上，她有点找错方向了。但无论如何，多米尼克，告诉我们关于……好吧，让我们看看。让我们看看，对吧？所以，西克特出生于1860年。
So he is the right age. He's in his late 20s when the... It's 28, when the killings happen. Sikit was fascinated by city culture, by kind of seediness, by prostitution, by musical scenes. He painted lots of pictures of lodging houses and Doss houses. This is not terribly unusual in the late 1880s. I mean, he's very influenced by the French Impressionist, by Edgar Degas, in particular. We know that he was fascinated by murders and mysteries.
所以他的年龄正合适。谋杀案发生时他20多岁。是28岁。西克特对城市文化、那种肮脏、卖淫、音乐场景很着迷。他画了很多关于廉租房和收容所的画。这在19世纪80年代末并不算太不寻常。我的意思是，他深受法国印象派的影响，特别是埃德加·德加。我们知道他非常着迷于谋杀和谜团。
So he's very interested in the case that we've done before on this podcast with Zadie Smith, the case of the Titch-born claimant. He was really interested in that. Sikert painted a picture called Jack the Ripper's bedroom in 1996. It was his bedroom of his own lodging house in Sixth Mornington Crescent. And the landlady told him, that she thought the previous tenant had been Jack the Ripper. We don't know on what basis, though.
所以他对我们之前在这个播客中与扎迪·史密斯一起讨论过的案件非常感兴趣，即蒂奇伯恩诉讼案。他真的对那个很感兴趣。西克特在1996年画了一幅名为《开膛手杰克的卧室》的画。那是他自己在莫宁顿新月6号的廉租房卧室。女房东告诉他，她认为之前的租客就是开膛手杰克。不过我们不知道依据是什么。
No, she said he used to go out a lot of nights, and I noticed he went out on the nights of the killings. Of course, if Sicker was the Ripper, he must have concealed a wry smile at that. Then in 1908, he painted a series of pictures called the Camden Town Murder. So the Camden Town murder was the murder of her prostitute called Emily Dimmock,
不，她说他经常晚上出去，我注意到他在谋杀案发生的那些晚上也出去了。当然，如果西克特是开膛手，他听到这话时一定会暗自发笑。然后在1908年，他画了一系列名为《卡姆登镇谋杀案》的画。所以卡姆登镇谋杀案是一名妓女艾米丽·迪莫克的谋杀案，
and she was murdered in her lodginghouse bedroom in, I think, 1908, and the case was very much in the news at the time. And Sickett's pictures, they show, the pictures in this series show a man who's fully dressed sitting on a bed next to a naked woman. Now, some critics think that actually they weren't really pictures of the Camden Town murder. The Sickett was a great self-publicist. He had a brilliant eye for getting people's attention. And that actually he painted the pictures and then came up with the title afterwards to explain them. Anyway, that's a kind of side note.
她在1908年左右在她的廉租房卧室里被谋杀，当时这个案件在新闻中非常轰动。西克特的画作显示，这个系列中的画作展示了一个衣冠楚楚的男人坐在一个裸体女人旁边的床上。现在，一些评论家认为，实际上它们并不是真正的卡姆登镇谋杀案的画作。西克特是一个伟大的自我宣传者。他有吸引人们注意力的绝佳眼光。实际上是他先画了画，然后才想出标题来解释它们。无论如何，这只是一个旁注。
Patricia Cornwell and her people who believe her theories believe that these paintings actually depict the murders of Catherine Eddows and Mary Jane Kelly, that Sickett arranged characters in the pictures to mimic the murders and that these are his little clues and he is kind of taunting us with his knowledge of his own crimes. Now, the thing is, if you look at the pictures, the pictures are not as graphic and gory as you might expect from my description. They actually, if you Google them, they feel kind of sad and shabby and kind of melancholy. They do not feel to me like the works of a man who eviscerated his victims in a frenzy.
帕特里夏·康薇尔和那些相信她理论的人认为，这些画作实际上描绘了凯瑟琳·埃多斯和玛丽·简·凯利的谋杀案，西克特在画中安排了人物来模仿谋杀案，这些是他留下的微小线索，他用自己对罪行的了解来嘲弄我们。现在的问题是，如果你看这些画，它们并不像我描述的那样生动和血腥。实际上，如果你谷歌一下它们，它们会让人感觉有点悲伤、破旧和忧郁。在我看来，它们不像是一个在狂乱中将受害者开膛破肚的人的作品。
I mean, and if it's Mary Jane Kelly, they certainly don't replicate the horror of her dismemberment. No, not at all. And actually, there's a, I mentioned it a couple of times. There's a brilliant website. I mean, this is the kind of rabbit hole down which you fall and you will never come back up again. called the case book, I think, a Jack the Ripper case book or something. And there's an essay on this website by Garker, Wolf van der Linden, all about Sikert's art and whether it relates to the Ripper.
我的意思是，如果是玛丽·简·凯利，它们肯定没有重现她被肢解的恐怖。不，一点也不。事实上，有一个，我提过几次。有一个很棒的网站。我的意思是，这就是那种你会掉进去就再也出不来的兔子洞。叫“案例书”，我想，叫“开膛手杰克案例书”之类的。这个网站上有一篇由加克、沃尔夫·范·德·林登写的文章，全是关于西克特的艺术以及它是否与开膛手有关。
And he points out that Siket painted prostitutes in Venice in 1903, and he wrote afterwards how much he enjoyed doing it. He loved working with them, these pretty obliging little models who laugh and unembarrassedly be themselves while posing like angels. It is an uninterrupted joy to paint them. And Vandalindon says in his essay, this doesn't sound like a serial killer talking about his victims. This is actually a bloke who's just like, you know, he enjoys their company and is having fun
他指出，西克特在1903年在威尼斯画过妓女，他后来写道他有多么喜欢这样做。他喜欢和她们一起工作，这些漂亮、顺从的小模特，她们笑着，毫无顾忌地做自己，同时像天使一样摆姿势。画她们是一种不间断的快乐。范·德·林登在他的文章中说，这听起来不像是一个连环杀手在谈论他的受害者。这实际上是一个家伙，你知道，他享受她们的陪伴，玩得很开心，
and he enjoys their hedonistic, uninhibited ways. He's not tortured with self-loathing or loathing of them when he's doing it, right? Now, you mentioned stamps in George V. Patricia Cornwell got some DNA from a stamp licked by Walter Sickers, and she compared it with the DNA in the Ripper Letters. And she said, there's a match here, there's a definite match. actually the match, you know, as much as 10% of the population could have this same DNA. And the letters are hoaxes, almost certainly.
他享受她们那种享乐主义、无拘无束的生活方式。他在画画时并没有被自我厌恶或对她们的厌恶所折磨，对吧？现在，你提到了乔治五世的邮票。帕特里夏·康薇尔从沃尔特·西克特舔过的邮票上提取了一些DNA，并将其与开膛手信件中的DNA进行了比较。她说，这里有一个匹配，绝对匹配。实际上这个匹配，你知道，多达10%的人口可能拥有相同的DNA。而且这些信件几乎可以肯定是恶作剧。
And if the letters are hoaxes, which they probably are, then that doesn't tell you anything. So I think DNA testing is a kind of, it seems like a massive opportunity for riparologists, but there is barely an example of it being used that doesn't come across as mad. Exactly. I think it's a kind of a terrible temptation that should be resisted. There are a couple of other big problems with the Wolter Sickett. thesis. Number one, Walter Sickett lived until 1942. Is it plausible
如果这些信件是恶作剧，而它们很可能就是，那么这什么也说明不了。所以我认为DNA测试是一种，对开膛手研究者来说似乎是一个巨大的机会，但几乎没有一个例子使用它而不显得疯狂。完全正确。我认为这是一种应该抵制的巨大诱惑。关于沃尔特·西克特的论点还有几个其他大问题。第一，沃尔特·西克特一直活到1942年。这可信吗？
that he carried out these killings in an escalating frenzy and then just stopped and never did anything like it again? The youthful jeadespé. Yeah, we've all behaved badly in our youth, haven't we, at times? The other thing is, Walter Sickett lived on and off in France during the late 1880s, and his biographer, Matthew Sturgis, says, you know, I'm pretty certain he was in France.
他在19世纪80年代末进行了这些杀戮，处于一种不断升级的狂乱中，然后就停止了，再也没有做过类似的事情？年轻时的轻率。是的，我们年轻时都表现得不好，不是吗，有时？另一件事是，沃尔特·西克特在19世纪80年代末断断续续地住在法国，他的传记作者马修·斯特吉斯说，你知道，我非常确定他在法国。
for at least four of these killings, which I think is insuperable. The one thing I will say, however, I noticed that in the studio chat of this podcast, Aaliyah, who is herself German, says, never trust a German. So maybe we should put that into the balance as well. And maybe she's right and sicker is the culprit. But if Aaliyah is German and says never trust a German, you can't trust her. It's the Creight and liar, right? Anyway, on that paradoxical note, I think we should take a break.
至少有四起谋杀案发生时他在法国，我认为这是无法克服的证据。不过，我要说的一件事是，我注意到在这个播客的演播室聊天中，本身是德国人的阿利亚说，永远不要相信德国人。所以也许我们也应该把这一点考虑进去。也许她是正确的，西克特就是罪魁祸首。但如果阿利亚是德国人并且说永远不要相信德国人，你就不能相信她。这是克里特岛人的谎言，对吧？无论如何，带着这个悖论，我想我们应该休息一下。
We've looked at the mad theories that I don't think anyone really believes, except perhaps from those who propose them. And we will be back after the break to look at some of the suspects who are more credible, perhaps. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense, and Mur, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. Some of those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning.
我们已经看过了那些我认为没人真正相信的疯狂理论，除了那些提出它们的人。休息后我们将回来看看一些可能更可信的嫌疑人。纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予。所以罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人绝对喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。其中一些是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们对于典型的圣诞节早晨来说是否太奢侈了。
So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers, why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history club membership? It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening, you get a weekly bonus episode, you get early access to live shows, and you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the cool people in your neighbourhood. If such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you.
所以今年，这是我给听众和观众的建议，为什么不给一些更有启发性的东西呢？为什么不送一份“其余皆历史”俱乐部会员资格作为礼物？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。它是无广告收听，你每周会得到一集额外节目，你可以提前观看现场演出，还可以获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年“其余皆历史”俱乐部会员资格的特别礼品版还附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有邻居和社区里酷人们羡慕的对象。如果这样的人存在，他们会钦佩你并想花更多时间和你在一起。
So just head to the rest is history.com and click on gifts. That is therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. Hello, I'm Professor Hannah Fry. And I'm Michael Stevens, creator of Vsauce. We thought we would join you for a moment, completely uninvited. We are not going to stay too long. Unless you want us to, of course. We're here to tell you about our brand new show.
所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”。那是therestishistory.com，请点击“礼物”。你好，我是汉娜·弗莱教授。我是迈克尔·史蒂文斯，Vsauce的创作者。我们想不请自来地加入你们一会儿。我们不会待太久。除非你希望我们待久一点，当然。我们来这里是为了告诉你们关于我们的新节目。
The rest is science. Every episode is going to start with something that feels initially, familiar. And then we're going to unpick it and tear it apart until you no longer recognize it at all. Yeah, banana flavor doesn't taste like bananas. Yeah, what is that about? So it is supposed to taste like an old species of banana that was wiped out in a banana apocalypse. And now you will only find it in botanical collections in the gardens of billionaires. Wow. Banana candy is actually the ghost of a long extinct banana. So if you like scratching the surface, thinking a little bit deeper or weirder.
《其余皆科学》。每一集都将从一些最初感觉熟悉的事情开始。然后我们将拆解它，把它撕碎，直到你完全认不出它为止。是的，香蕉味尝起来不像香蕉。是的，那是怎么回事？所以它应该尝起来像一种在香蕉末日中被消灭的古老香蕉品种。现在你只能在亿万富翁花园的植物收藏中找到它。哇。香蕉糖实际上是一种早已灭绝的香蕉的幽灵。所以如果你喜欢挖掘表面，思考得更深或更奇怪。
Yes, definitely that too. You can join Michael and I every Tuesday and Thursday wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to The Restis History. This is shaping up, as our team have just been discussing, and with great delight, I have to say, and they're really excited to work out that this is shaping up to be one of our longest ever episodes because we are deep into going through the suspects in the case of Jack the Ripper. We have dismissed the Madder suspects. We are now going to look at the more serious suspects and we're going to start with the suspects that were propounded by Inspector
是的，绝对也是那样。你可以在每周二和周四加入迈克尔和我，无论你在哪里收听播客。欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。正如我们的团队刚才讨论的那样，我必须说，他们非常高兴，而且他们非常兴奋地发现，这一集正在成为我们有史以来最长的一集，因为我们正在深入研究开膛手杰克案的嫌疑人。我们已经排除了更疯狂的嫌疑人。我们现在要看看更严肃的嫌疑人，我们将从弗雷德里克·阿伯莱恩督察提出的嫌疑人开始。
Frederick Abiline. So this is somebody who knew the case better than anybody. He knew Whitechapel. He was regarded by his peers. They compared him with the bank manager. He's the soul of respectability and hard work. And yet he too has some mad theories, Tom. Right? Well, I'm not sure they're mad. He has two good theories. And the first of these theories, he proposes in the wake of the murder of Mary Jane Kelly.
所以这是一个比任何人都更了解这个案件的人。他了解白教堂区。他受到同行的尊敬。他们把他比作银行经理。他是正直和勤奋的化身。然而，汤姆，他也有一些疯狂的理论。对吧？嗯，我不确定它们是否疯狂。他有两个很好的理论。而这些理论中的第一个，是在玛丽·简·凯利被谋杀后提出的。
And it's prompted by the fact that he interviews a couple of witnesses who claim to have seen Mary Jane Kelly around 8 o'clock or 9 o'clock in the morning by which. time, it would seem that she is dead. So someone dressed in Mary Jane Kelly's clothes. And so he comes to a brilliant solution. What if the murderer of Mary Jane Kelly was not actually a man, but a woman? And that this woman had then dressed up in Mary Jane Kelly's clothes to make her getaway. And so when the witnesses thought that they had seen Mary Jane Kelly, actually the person they'd seen was her killer. Then, of course, he has to come up with a reason why it would be a woman rather than a man. And listeners will have noted that we have been operating under the assumption throughout this series that the killer is a man. And so the revelation that in fact
这是因为他采访了几个声称在早上8点或9点左右看到玛丽·简·凯利的证人，而到那个时候，她似乎已经死了。所以有人穿着玛丽·简·凯利的衣服。于是他想出了一个绝妙的解决方案。如果玛丽·简·凯利的凶手实际上不是男人，而是女人呢？而且这个女人随后穿上了玛丽·简·凯利的衣服来逃脱。所以当证人们以为他们看到了玛丽·简·凯利时，实际上他们看到的是她的杀手。然后，当然，他必须想出一个为什么是女人而不是男人的理由。听众们会注意到，我们在整个系列中一直假设凶手是男人。所以事实上，这可能是一个女人的揭露，
it might be a woman is exactly the kind of twist that you would expect in a detective story, isn't it? Yeah. No, no one had thought of it. But actually, when you see it, you think, yeah, actually, yeah, that would kind of work. Because, of course, you know, when the police are busy looking for a male killer, a woman would be able to stalk the streets disemboweling other women without necessarily being noticed in quite the way that a man would.
这正是你在侦探小说中会期待的那种转折，不是吗？是的。不，没有人想到过这一点。但实际上，当你看到它时，你会想，是的，实际上，是的，那会行得通。因为，当然，你知道，当警察忙于寻找男性杀手时，一个女人将能够在街上跟踪其他女人并将她们开膛破肚，而不一定像男人那样被注意到。
And what kind of woman would be the likeliest to be able to get away with it? And the answer, of course, as I put to my wife, Sadie, last night when I were talking about this, is a midwife. Sadie is a midwife, and she wasn't very happy with this theory. But just to give Abiline's reasons for proposing it, it would be perfectly natural for a midwife to be out late at night. There's no rhyme or reason as to when babies are being delivered. So perfectly acceptable. midwives are dealing with blood. So again, if her skirts are spattered with blood, I mean, that would be unsurprising. And of course, Dominant, you mentioned that the killer displays anatomical knowledge. Of course, the midwife absolutely has anatomical knowledge. And there's been, you know, in the murders, there's a particular emphasis on the uterus and on the private parts of the victims. So exactly what you might expect from a midwife. And so this theory is called the Jill the Ripper theory.
什么样的女人最有可能逃脱惩罚？答案当然是，正如我昨晚和我的妻子萨迪谈论这件事时所说的那样，是助产士。萨迪是一名助产士，她对这个理论不太高兴。但为了给出阿伯莱恩提出这个理论的理由，助产士在深夜外出是完全自然的。婴儿出生的时间没有任何规律可循。所以完全可以接受。助产士在处理血液。所以同样，如果她的裙子上溅满了血，我的意思是，那并不令人惊讶。当然，多米尼克，你提到凶手表现出了人体解剖学知识。当然，助产士绝对拥有解剖学知识。而且，你知道，在谋杀案中，特别强调了子宫和受害者的私处。所以这正是你可能从助产士那里期待的。所以这个理论被称为“开膛手吉尔”理论。
Aaliyah calls it the Jackie the Ripper theory. Yeah, I mean, I like Jackie the Ripper, but it's recorded in the annals of Ripperology as Jill the Ripper. And you can't disprove it. No, I can't disprove it, but equally, well, it just seems absolutely deranged. Because it doesn't make sense of all the men who were talking to the victims. There's no female candidate. It's very unusual for serial killers. There are female serial killers, but they don't tend to target other women, I don't think.
阿利亚称之为“开膛手杰基”理论。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢“开膛手杰基”，但它在开膛手学的编年史中被记录为“开膛手吉尔”。而且你无法反驳它。不，我无法反驳它，但同样，嗯，它看起来绝对是精神错乱。因为它无法解释所有与受害者交谈的男人。没有女性候选人。这对于连环杀手来说非常不寻常。有女性连环杀手，但我不认为她们倾向于以其他女性为目标。
Right. And what is the motivation? I think the guiding assumption is that there's some degree of sexual motivation, but this is almost unheard of in female serial killers targeting other women. Yes. So let's part that one. It's an interesting theory, but probably implausible. But he then comes up with, later on, he comes up with another theory.
对。动机是什么？我认为指导假设是存在某种程度的性动机，但这在以其他女性为目标的女性连环杀手中几乎是闻所未闻的。是的。所以让我们把那个放在一边。这是一个有趣的理论，但可能不可信。但他后来又提出了另一个理论。
And this is held to be plausible, isn't it? Much more plausible. So Philip Sugden, it's. kind of says unproven on this. Yeah, so this is the first person that some listeners to this may say, this could actually be Jack the Ripper. This is a guy who was known by the name of George Chapman, but that wasn't his real name. It was actually a pole.
这被认为是可信的，不是吗？更可信。所以菲利普·萨格登，它。有点说这个未经证实。是的，所以这是第一位一些听众可能会说的人，这可能是开膛手杰克。这是一个以乔治·查普曼为名的人，但那不是他的真名。他实际上是一个波兰人。
He was born Severin Kwasovsky in Nagorno in Poland in 1865, and he became a surgeon's apprentice. He went to Warsaw. He trained in surgery at the Prager Hospital in Warsaw. Sometime in late 1887 or early 1888, Kwasovsky moves to London. and he becomes a barber's assistant in the East End and then he opens his own barber's shop. He marries another Polish woman in 1889. You'll notice I've skipped over the period of the murders.
他于1865年出生在波兰纳戈尔诺，原名塞韦林·克瓦索夫斯基，他成为了一名外科医生的学徒。他去了华沙。他在华沙的普拉格医院接受了外科培训。1887年底或1888年初的某个时候，克瓦索夫斯基搬到了伦敦。他成为东区的一名理发师助理，然后开了自己的理发店。他在1889年娶了另一位波兰妇女。你会注意到我跳过了谋杀案发生的时期。
In 1889, by this time he's calling himself Ludwig Zagovsky. He speaks, we know at this point he speaks a mixture of Polish and Yiddish. He's a medium height, he's got dark hair. He and Lucy emigrate to Jersey City. They have a massive row. He attacks her with a knife. She returns home to London. He follows.
到1889年，此时他自称路德维希·扎戈夫斯基。他说话，我们知道此时他说的波兰语和意第绪语混合。他中等身材，留着深色头发。他和露西移民到泽西市。他们大吵了一架。他用刀袭击了她。她回到了伦敦。他跟着去了。
they end up separating. By the middle of the 1890s, Kuzovsky is a barber in Leighton stone, and he calls himself now George Chapman. He's taken an English name. He has a series of lovers, and he pretends to marry each of them. They have a kind of bogus marriage ceremony, because he says, this is how we do things in Poland. He's clearly a very violent and abusive partner. He beats up his so-called wives, and he escalates from that to murdering them. and he murders each of them with a thing called tartar emetic, which is a white powder, it's soluble in water, and if you dissolve it, it produces something called antimony. And if you have a large dose of this, it will make you sick, and so you won't, you know,
他们最终分开了。到19世纪90年代中期，克瓦索夫斯基是莱顿斯通的一名理发师，他现在自称乔治·查普曼。他取了一个英文名字。他有一系列情人，并假装娶了她们中的每一个。他们举行了一种虚假的结婚仪式，因为他说，这就是我们在波兰做事的方式。他显然是一个非常暴力和虐待的伴侣。他殴打他所谓的妻子，并从那升级到谋杀她们。他用一种叫酒石酸锑的东西谋杀她们中的每一个，这是一种白色粉末，它溶于水，如果你溶解它，它会产生一种叫锑的东西。如果你服用大剂量，它会让你生病，所以你不会，你知道，
you'll vomit it up. But if you have small doses over time, it will kill you. And this is how he kills them. He kills a woman called Mary Spink, then a woman called Bessie Taylor, and then a woman called Maud Marsh. But Morn Marsh's family demanded an investigation. The bodies are exhumed. And Timony preserves the bodies, so he is detected, and he is caught, and he has hanged. And in court, one writer who was watching him said, he seemed a particularly callous murderer.
你会把它呕吐出来。但如果你随着时间推移服用小剂量，它会杀死你。这就是他杀死她们的方式。他杀了一个叫玛丽·斯平克的女人，然后是一个叫贝西·泰勒的女人，然后是莫德·马什。但莫德·马什的家人要求调查。尸体被挖掘出来。锑保存了尸体，所以他被发现了，他被抓住了，他被绞死了。在法庭上，一位观察他的作家说，他似乎是一个特别冷酷的杀手。
While most people in court were horrified, he appeared to be amused. And on one occasion, while a sarcastic smile was spreading over his face, he caught sight of me, and he straightened his face and assumed a serious expression. So Chapman, or Kozovsky, is a very unpleasant man. why would he be the ripper? So this is Abiline's theory. Abiline laid out his thoughts in 1903 to a reporter from the Palmaal Gazette. He said, this guy ticks a lot of boxes.
当法庭上的大多数人都感到震惊时，他似乎感到很有趣。有一次，当讽刺的微笑在他脸上蔓延时，他看到了我，他挺直了脸，表现出严肃的表情。所以查普曼，或者说科佐夫斯基，是一个非常令人不快的人。为什么他会是开膛手？这就是阿伯莱恩的理论。阿伯莱恩在1903年向《帕尔马尔公报》的一名记者阐述了他的想法。他说，这家伙符合很多条件。
He's single at the time of the killings. At the time of the killings, he is working in his barber's shop in Cable Street nearby. So he's in regular work. In other words, he would strike at holidays and weekends. And he don't forget, he trained as a surgeon's apprentice. He's within walking distance of all the murder sites. He is a white man of medium height in his 20s, a tiny bit younger than some of the descriptions, but it's dark.
他在谋杀案发生时是单身。在谋杀案发生时，他在附近的电缆街的理发店工作。所以他有固定的工作。换句话说，他会在假期和周末作案。而且别忘了，他受过外科医生学徒的训练。他在所有谋杀地点的步行距离内。他是一个20多岁的白人，中等身材，比一些描述稍微年轻一点，但天很黑。
He has a moustache, and we have photographs of him wearing a peaked cap. I mean, crucially, he's violent to women, and he's a killer, and he's in the right place at the right time. There are a couple of problems with this. Number one, he's only just arrived in the area, late 1887-88, so how well does he know the area. I guess he's been there for a few months. You might know it quite well. Does he speak good enough English? Remember I said he spoke Polish and Yiddish, a kind of mixture of the two. Does he speak good enough English to be the person who's having conversations with the
他留着胡子，我们有他戴着尖顶帽的照片。我的意思是，至关重要的是，他对女性暴力，他是一个杀手，而且他在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。这有几个问题。第一，他刚到该地区，1887-88年底，所以他有多了解该地区。我想他在那里待了几个月。你可能很了解它。他的英语说得够好吗？记得我说过他说波兰语和意第绪语，两者混合。他的英语说得够好，能成为那个与证人观察到的
women watched by the witnesses? The biggest problem, the massive difference in the modus operandi. So if you're a guy who likes killing women, is it plausible that you will have this spree in 1888, where you eviscerate them and you clearly get your kicks from ever more extreme and horrific hits. Is it plausible that you'll go from that to a decade later, sort of pretending to marry women and poisoning them slowly, where you presumably don't get anything like the same thrill? And to me, that is the biggest problem with this theory, that the difference in the mode of killing is so stark that psychologically I struggle to see how it makes sense, frankly. We're not psychologists, so we couldn't say, but it does seem that there is a real
妇女交谈的人吗？最大的问题，作案手法上的巨大差异。所以如果你是一个喜欢杀害女性的家伙，那么他在1888年进行这种狂欢，在那里他将她们开膛破肚，并且显然从越来越极端和可怕的打击中获得快感，这可信吗？从那之后十年，假装娶女人并慢慢毒死她们，在那里你大概得不到同样的快感，这可信吗？对我来说，这是这个理论最大的问题，杀戮方式的差异如此鲜明，以至于坦率地说，从心理学上讲，我很难看出它有什么意义。我们不是心理学家，所以我们不能说，但确实似乎存在一个真正的
pointed difference between a death that is invisible and a death that involves the ripping open of a stomach. Right. Now, I can see how you could start as the poisoner and end up as the ripper, but I struggle to see. I mean, maybe I'm not a serial killer, so to go the other way around. Anyway, but Abilene wasn't the only policeman, was he, to come up with a list of plausible suspects? Because there's a guy called Sir Melvin McNaughton, and he has his own list, doesn't he? He does. So this is probably the single most famous document in the entire history of the search for Jack the Ripper.
尖锐的区别，在于隐形的死亡和涉及撕开胃部的死亡。对。现在，我可以看到你如何能以毒杀者开始，以开膛手结束，但我很难看到。我的意思是，也许我不是连环杀手，所以反过来走。无论如何，但阿伯莱恩不是唯一一个提出可信嫌疑人名单的警察，对吧？因为有一个叫梅尔维尔·麦克诺顿爵士的人，他有自己的名单，不是吗？他有。所以这可能是整个寻找开膛手杰克历史中最著名的单一文件。
And it was written in 1894 by this guy, Melville McNaughton, who would go on to become Sir Melville. McNaughton. And he was the assistant commissioner of the Metropolitan Police from 1903 to 1913 and a very, very serious figure. So he was of upper class background, unlike a lot of the police at the time. So he'd gone to Eaton and he was the youngest son of the chairman of the East India Company, interestingly. And Sugden says of him, it was said of him that he owned to only two disappointments in his life. One was that he was turned out of the Eaton 11 before a match with Harrow, so that's another cricket reference. And the other was that he became a detective six months after the Ripper committed suicide and quote unquote never had a go at that fascinating
它是由这个叫梅尔维尔·麦克诺顿的人在1894年写的，他后来成为了梅尔维尔·麦克诺顿爵士。他是1903年至1913年伦敦警察厅的助理局长，是一个非常非常严肃的人物。所以他有上层阶级的背景，不像当时很多警察。所以他去了伊顿公学，有趣的是，他是东印度公司董事长的最小儿子。萨格登这样评价他，据说他一生中只有两次失望。一次是他被伊顿公学11人队开除，在与哈罗公学的比赛之前，所以那是另一个板球参考。另一次是他成为侦探是在开膛手自杀六个月后，引用“从未有机会对付那个迷人的”
individual. He is the person who introduces the habit of fingerprinting to British policing, very late one might say, because it's not, I think, until 905. And he's also the person who directs the investigation into the case that sees the arrest of Dr. Crippin. So probably the most famous murderer after Jack the Ripper in British criminal history. So as I say, very serious figure. And when he writes this memorandum in February 1894, he is the assistant chief constable at the Metropolitan Police. And he writes this memorandum on the Ripper to repudic claims in the Sun, the New
个人。他是将指纹识别习惯引入英国警务的人，可以说非常晚，因为我认为直到905年才引入。他也是指导调查导致克里彭医生被捕的案件的人。所以可能是英国犯罪史上仅次于开膛手杰克的最著名的杀手。所以正如我所说，非常严肃的人物。当他在1894年2月写这份备忘录时，他是伦敦警察厅的助理总警司。他写这份关于开膛手的备忘录是为了反驳《太阳报》的说法，即一个叫托马斯·卡特布什的人是开膛手。卡特布什在1891年因袭击一名女孩和企图袭击另一名女孩而被捕。在此之后，他被送进了精神病院。伦敦警察厅已经调查了卡特布什可能是开膛手的可能性，并排除了他作为嫌疑人。这份备忘录有两份副本存在。所以提交给苏格兰场并多年后被发现的官方备忘录，因为人们忘记了它的存在。然后是一份早期的草稿，在他实际写完多年后，由他的女儿阿伯康威夫人从他的私人文件中发现。草稿基本相同。个人草稿有
paper that a man called Thomas Cutbush was the Ripper. And Cutbush had been arrested in 1891 after an attack on one girl and attempted an attack on another girl. And in the wake of this, he had been consigned to an asylum. And the Metropolitan Police had already investigated the possibility that Cutbush might have been the Ripper and had eliminated him as a suspect. And there are two copies of this memorandum in existence. So the official memorandum that was filed at Scotland Yard and was discovered years later because people had forgotten it existed. And then an earlier draft that was found years after he'd actually written it in his private papers by his daughter, Lady Aber Conway. And the drafts are basically the same. The personal draft has
稍微不同的措辞，有更多的个人观点和一些额外的细节，但本质上它们是一样的。所以麦克诺顿在这份备忘录中预先承认，没有人见过白教堂区的凶手。许多杀人狂被怀疑，但没有人能被证明。所以我认为这反驳了警察知道是谁做的并保密的想法。我的意思是，人们可能认为我这样说很天真，但我不这么认为。我认为这基本上是苏格兰场的观点。麦克诺顿随后列出了三个人，他说其中任何一个人都比卡特布什更有可能犯下这一系列谋杀案。在这些嫌疑人中，有一个人今天我认为排名压倒性地
slightly different wording, has more personal opinions and a few extra details, but essentially they're the same. So McNaughton in this memorandum acknowledges up front that no one ever saw the Whitechapel murderer. Many homicidal maniacs were suspected, but no shadow of proof could be thrown on anyone. So I think this refutes the idea that the police knew who had done it and were keeping it secret. I mean, people may think I'm being naive in saying that, but I don't think so. I think that this is basically the opinion of Scotland Yard. And McNaughton then goes on to list three men, and he says any one of whom would have been more likely than Cutbush to have committed this series of murders. And among these suspects is the man who today, I think, ranks overwhelmingly
作为头号嫌疑人。所以，多米尼克，这个人是谁，你觉得他作为嫌疑人有多可信？好的。所以他是一个叫亚伦·科斯明斯基的人。现在，麦克诺顿在他的备忘录中说，描述如下。一名波兰犹太人，居住在白教堂区。这个人因多年沉溺于孤独的恶习而变得疯狂。他非常憎恨女性，尤其是妓女阶层，并有强烈的杀人倾向。他于1889年3月左右被送往精神病院。关于这个人有很多情况，使他成为一个强有力的嫌疑人。那么我们对科斯明斯基了解多少？科斯明斯基在谋杀案发生时，是一个未婚的、
as top suspect. So, Dominic, who is this man and how plausible do you find him as a suspect? All right. So he's a man called Aaron Cosminsky. Now, McNaughton in his memo says, describes him as follows. A Polish Jew and resident in Whitechapel. This man became insane owing to many years indulgence in solitary vices. He had a great hatred of women, especially the prostitute class, and had strong homicidal tendencies. He was removed to a lunatic asylum about March 1889. There were many circumstances connected with this man, which made him a strong suspect. So what do we know about Cosminsky? Cosminsky was, at the time of the murders, he was an unmarried,
来自波兰犹太背景的理发师。实际上，我之前提到过开膛手研究者。有一位叫罗伯特·豪斯的开膛手研究者，他对科斯明斯基的背景做了大量的研究。它发现了很多实际上取代了菲利普·萨尔顿书中描述的东西。所以我们现在对科斯明斯基了解的是，他于1865年出生在波兰一个叫夸达瓦的地方。他在19世纪80年代与他的兄弟移民到伦敦。可能是沙皇帝国大屠杀的结果。
Barber from a Polish-Jewish background. And actually, I mentioned riparologists before. There's a riparologist called Robert House, who did loads of research on Kosminsky's background. It's turned up lots of stuff that actually supersedes the description in Philip Sulton's book. So what we now know about Kosminski is he's born in a place called Kwadava in Poland in 1865. He immigrated with his brother to London in the 1880s. probably as a result of the pogroms in the Tsarist Empire.
他住在白教堂区。他做理发师助理，但只是偶尔。1889年12月，他因养了一只没戴口套的狗而惹上了警察。然后从19世纪90年代初开始，他进出济贫院和精神病院。科斯明斯基先生显然是一个深受困扰的人。引用一份医生报告，他宣称他受到一种告知他思想的本能的引导，他的行动完全受到控制。他说他知道全人类的动向。他拒绝吃别人的食物，因为他被告知要这样做，
He lived in Whitechapel. He worked as this barbassist system, but only occasionally. In December 1889, he was in trouble with the police for having an unmuzzled dog. And then from the early 1890s, he's in and out of workhouses and asylums. Mr. Kosminski is very clearly a deeply disturbed man. At a quote, a doctor's report, he declares that he is guided and his movements altogether controlled by an instinct that informs his mind. He says he knows the movements of all mankind. He refuses food from others because he is told to do so
并出于同样的原因吃阴沟里的东西。换句话说，他听到了告诉他吃阴沟里东西的声音。现在，关于这个家伙科斯明斯基，从他的济贫院和精神病院里有很多不同的病例记录，绝大多数描述他是一个非常懒惰、冷漠、被动的人。其中一个，也只有一个提到了暴力。有时语无伦次，兴奋且暴力，几天前他拿起一把椅子，试图袭击负责的侍从，但随后又说，通常冷漠，拒绝以任何方式占用自己，
and eats out of the gutter for the same reason. In other words, he's hearing voices that tell him to eat out of the gutter. Now, there are lots of different case notes about this guy, Kosminski from his workhouses and asylums, and the vast majority describe him as a very lazy, apathetic, passive man. One of them and only one mentions violence. incoherent at times excited and violent a few days ago he took up a chair and attempted to strike the charge attendant but then it goes on to say apathetic is a rule and refuses to occupy himself
习惯干净，健康状况良好，在1900年代和1910年代，关于他的记录也类似。然后他在1990年去世。所以这个家伙科斯明斯基是开膛手吗？如果你回到麦克诺顿所说的，麦克诺顿说他沉溺于孤独的恶习。绝对没有理由知道这有多真实。他非常憎恨女性，尤其是妓女阶层，并有强烈的杀人倾向。对此绝对没有任何证据。
in any way habits cleanly health fare and there are similar notes on him all the way through 1900s and 1910s then he ends up dying in 1990 so is this guy cosminski the ripper If you go back to what McNaughton said McNaughton said that he had indulged in solitary vices There's absolutely no reason to know whether that's how true that is He had a great hatred of women, especially the prostitute class And strong homicidal tendencies There is absolutely no evidence for that whatsoever
麦克诺顿要么是被误导了，要么是在重复流言，要么只是在编造东西。他被送往精神病院，不是吗？他在1889年3月左右，所以这也许可以解释为什么谋杀案停止了。我们被告知的一件暴力事情是他拿起一把椅子，试图打那个进来叫他去喝茶之类的家伙。我的意思是，那并不
McNaughton there is either misinformed Or he's repeating gossip Or he's just making stuff up He is removed to a lunatic asylum isn't he He is About March 1889 so that would explain why the murder stopped perhaps. The one violent thing we're told is that he picks up a chair and tries to hit the bloke who's coming in to kind of tell him to come for his tea or something. I mean, that doesn't
坦率地说，这让我觉得不是杀人倾向的迹象。他非常矮小，因为他只吃阴沟里的食物。所以那个是开膛手，正在和女人交谈，大概，你知道，和她们达成交易，和她们一起进入房间，或者和她们一起进入庭院之类的家伙，肯定不是像科斯明斯基那样招摇的疯子。更重要的是，没有任何理由相信科斯明斯基有任何解剖学知识或技能。
strike me as the sign of, you know, homicidal tendencies, frankly. He's very short and slight because he only eats food out of the gutter. So the guy who's the ripper who's talking to the women and presumably, you know, going with them, making a deal and going with them into rooms or going with them into courtyards or whatever is not surely an ostentatious madman as Cosminsky is. What is more, there is no reason at all to believe that Cosminsky has any anatomical knowledge or skill.
你知道，没有什么能暗示这一点。而且正是因为他没有暴力史，没有对女性暴力的记录，没有仇恨女性的记录之类的，很难把他看作是开膛手，除非汤姆有相反的DNA证据。我知道你特别喜欢一点DNA证据，不是吗？所以2014年，一位叫拉塞尔·爱德华兹的作家将他命名为开膛手，并说他拿到了凯瑟琳·埃多斯的披肩。我的意思是，我必须说，他拿到了
You know, there's nothing to suggest that. And precisely because he has no history of violence, no record of violence towards women, no record of hating women or anything like that, it is very hard to see that him as the, the Ripper, unless Tom there's DNA evidence to the contrary. And I know you like a bit of DNA evidence in particular, don't you? So in 2014, a writer called Russell Edwards named him as the Ripper and said he'd got hold of Catherine Eddo's shawl. I mean, I have to say, he'd got what
看起来是凯瑟琳·埃多斯的披肩。我的意思是，这比他在eBay上买的之类的东西高出一级。因为没有证据表明那是凯瑟琳·埃多斯的披肩。不，根本没有偏好。而且，还有很多人摸过那条披肩。无论如何，他测试了它的DNA，他说，哦，这显然是同一个人。我的意思是，我抓到他了，你知道。但同样，DNA证据从来不能解决任何问题。它只能将其缩小到一系列概率。而且我不认为这个，我实际上只是不认为这个家伙科斯明斯基。没有任何理由相信这个家伙科斯明斯基是开膛手。唯一可能让你犹豫的是他在谋杀案结束后不久就被送进了精神病院。但除此之外，他
appeared to be Catherine Edith's a shawl. I mean, it's one step up from he'd bought it on eBay or something like that. Because there's no evidence that it was Catherine O'Don's Shaw. No, no preference at all. And also, loads of people who touched the shawl. Anyway, he tested it for DNA and he said, oh, it's clearly the same man. I mean, I've got him, you know. But again, the DNA evidence never solves anything. It only narrows it down to a series of probabilities. And I don't think this, I actually just don't think this guy, Cosminski. There's any reason to believe this guy, Cosminski, is the, is the ripper. The only thing that might give you pause is the fact that he's put in an asylum not long after the murder's end. But apart from that, he
看起来像是凯瑟琳·埃迪斯的披肩。我的意思是，这比他在eBay上买的之类的东西要好一点。因为没有证据表明那是凯瑟琳·埃多斯的披肩。不，完全没有证据。而且，还有很多人碰过那条披肩。总之，他检测了上面的DNA，他说，哦，这显然是同一个人。我的意思是，我抓到他了，你知道的。但话说回来，DNA证据从来都解决不了任何问题。它只能将范围缩小到一系列概率。而且我不认为这个家伙，科斯明斯基。没有任何理由相信这个家伙，科斯明斯基，就是那个开膛手。唯一可能让你犹豫的是，他在谋杀案结束后不久就被送进了精神病院。但除此之外，他
just, to me, he just doesn't fit the bill at all. I mean, the DNA evidence has had quite a striking impact, despite the fact, I mean, so my friend Adam Rutherford wrote about it, and he said that the DNA evidence for Richard the third being Richard the third was, you know, the gold standard. And the proposition that this shawl proved that Kosminski had been the Ripper was absolutely the worst. So I'm prepared to take him, you know, he knows what he's talking about. But I did the experiment before we started this of typing into various AI programs. who is the most likely suspect in the Jack the Ripper case. They all said Cosminsky.
对我来说，他根本就不符合条件。我的意思是，DNA证据的影响力相当大，尽管事实上——我的朋友亚当·卢瑟福写过关于这件事的文章，他说理查三世是理查三世的DNA证据是黄金标准。而认为这条披肩证明了科斯明斯基就是开膛手杰克的说法绝对是最糟糕的。所以我准备接受他的观点，你知道，他很清楚自己在说什么。但在我们开始之前，我做了一个实验，在各种人工智能程序中输入：谁是开膛手杰克案中最可能的嫌疑人。它们都说是科斯明斯基。
And so it kind of confirms me in my opinion that AI is absolutely capable of spouting absolutely rubbish. But as you say, Dominic, the one thing in his favour is that there's an explanation for why the murder stop, because Cosminsky is put into an asylum early in 1889. And with a second candidate, a guy called Montague John Druitt, there is the same thing that clearly appealed to McNaughton because, well, as we'll see, there's a reason why if Druitt was Jack the Ripper, why he would have stopped after Miller's court. And to be clear, for McNaughton, Druitt is by far the leading candidate, right? Yes. So he writes, the more I think
这在某种程度上证实了我的观点，即人工智能绝对有能力胡说八道。但正如你所说，多米尼克，他唯一有利的一点是，对于谋杀案为何停止有一个解释，因为科斯明斯基在1889年初被送进了精神病院。而对于第二个候选人，一个叫蒙塔古·约翰·德鲁伊特的人，情况也是一样，这显然吸引了麦克诺顿，因为，嗯，正如我们将看到的，如果德鲁伊特是开膛手杰克，他为什么会在米勒法庭案后停止作案是有原因的。明确一点，对麦克诺顿来说，德鲁伊特是目前为止最主要的嫌疑人，对吧？是的。所以他写道，我越是思考
the matter over, the stronger do these opinions become that he is the likely suspect. And why? Well, I'll read what he has to say about Druid. So Mr. M.J. Druitt, Montague-John drew it, a doctor of about 41 years of age and a fairly good family who disappeared at the time of the Miller's Court murder and whose body was found floating in the Thames on the 31st of December, i.e. seven weeks after the said murder. So that basically is why McNarton thinks that he is such a likely candidate. The body was said to have been in the water for a month or more on it was found a season ticket between Blackheath and London. From private information, I have little doubt, but that his own family suspected this man of being the Whitechapel murderer.
这件事，就越坚信他是最可能的嫌疑人。为什么？好吧，我来读读他关于德鲁伊特的评价。M.J.德鲁伊特先生，蒙塔古·约翰·德鲁伊特，一位大约41岁的医生，出身于一个相当不错的家庭，在米勒法庭谋杀案发生时失踪，他的尸体于12月31日，也就是上述谋杀案发生七周后，被发现漂浮在泰晤士河上。这基本上就是麦克诺顿认为他是一个如此可能的候选人的原因。据说尸体在水中浸泡了一个月或更久，在尸体上发现了一张黑希斯到伦敦的季票。根据私人信息，我几乎可以肯定，他的家人怀疑这个人就是白教堂谋杀案的凶手。
It was alleged that he was sexually insane. Now, Montague Druitt is very much the kind of man who would have been at home in a top hat and an opera cloak. So he went to Winchester. He went to New College, Oxford. Again, the cricket theme, he was an excellent cricketer. He was a member of the MCC. He spent most of the summer of 1888 playing cricket bariously in Dorset and Blackheath.
据称他有性变态。现在，蒙塔古·德鲁伊特非常像那种戴着高礼帽、披着歌剧斗篷会感到自在的人。他去了温彻斯特。他去了牛津大学新学院。还是那个板球主题，他是一位出色的板球运动员。他是马里波恩板球俱乐部（MCC）的成员。1888年夏天的大部分时间，他都在多塞特和黑希斯打板球。
which is now a part of southeast London. What was he doing in Dorset? He'd been born there, and he worked part-time as a barrister on the Western Circuit in neighbouring Hampshire. And the reason that he was in Blackheath is that outside of the holidays, he was teaching at a boarding school there.
也就是现在的伦敦东南部。他在多塞特做什么？他出生在那里，并在邻近的汉普郡担任西部巡回法院的兼职大律师。他之所以在黑希斯，是因为在假期之外，他在那里的一所寄宿学校教书。
So he's very well off. He's both a barrister and a schoolteacher, and he has an active social life. He seems to be very popular. He seems to have his whole life before him. But then, as McNaughton says in his memorandum, on the 31st of December 1818, 8, his body had been fished out of the Thames and he had clearly committed suicide. And everyone was shocked by this. So the local newspaper in Blackheath commemorated him.
所以他非常富有。他既是大律师又是学校老师，而且社交生活活跃。他似乎非常受欢迎。他似乎前途无量。但正如麦克诺顿在备忘录中所说，1888年12月31日，他的尸体从泰晤士河中被打捞出来，他显然是自杀了。每个人都对此感到震惊。所以黑希斯的当地报纸纪念了他。
He was well known and much respected in the neighbourhood. He was a barrister of bright talent. He had a promising future before him. And his untimely end is deeply deplored. So what on earth could have driven him to commit suicide? And McNaughton's theory is that he is overcome with grief and despair at the horrors that he inflicted on the body of Mary Jane Kelly and on all the previous victims, and that after the climactic apocalypse of Miller's court, he was so appalled that he threw himself into the Thames. So, to put it in McNaughton's words, the murderer's brain gave away altogether after his awful glut in Miller's court, and he immediately committed suicide. Now, as we've said, we're not psychologists, but I gather that this is not how serial killers operate.
他在附近很有名，也备受尊敬。他是一位才华横溢的大律师。他前途无量。他的英年早逝令人深感惋惜。那么到底是什么驱使他自杀呢？麦克诺顿的理论是，他因对玛丽·简·凯利和所有前任受害者造成的恐怖行径而感到悲痛和绝望，在米勒法庭那场高潮般的末日景象之后，他感到如此震惊，以至于投身泰晤士河。用麦克诺顿的话说，凶手在米勒法庭那场可怕的暴行之后，大脑彻底崩溃，随即自杀。现在，正如我们所说，我们不是心理学家，但我认为连环杀手并不是这样运作的。
There is apparently no example of a serial killer being so ashamed of a killing spree that he or she then commits suicide. So I think that this is a massive problem for the Montague-Druitt theory, because there isn't really any other evidence aside from that that he might have been the murderer. Just a quick question. If he didn't kill himself because he was the Ripper, do we know or do we have any idea why he would have taken his own life? His mother had been confined to an asylum in July 1888. so I don't know perhaps he's upset about that perhaps depression runs in the family I mean there's no evidence aside from what McNaughton says that he was insane let alone sexually insane nor is there any evidence that anyone has ever found that
显然没有连环杀手因为对杀戮狂潮感到羞愧而自杀的例子。所以我认为这对蒙塔古·德鲁伊特的理论来说是一个巨大的问题，因为除了这一点，真的没有任何其他证据表明他可能是凶手。问个简单的问题。如果他不是因为是开膛手而自杀，我们知道或有任何头绪他为什么要自杀吗？他的母亲在1888年7月被关进了精神病院。所以我不知道，也许他对此感到难过，也许抑郁症在家族中遗传。我的意思是，除了麦克诺顿所说的，没有证据表明他精神失常，更不用说有性变态了，也没有人发现任何证据表明
Druitt's family suspected him of having been the Ripper beyond what McNaughton says and it's notable that even McNaughton is expressing himself in a kind of quite a havering way so I little doubt but that. I mean, that's, you know, he's not saying he definitely was. On the other hand, he's a cricketer. So that's a definite, that's a very bad sign. No, I don't think so. I don't think that you can be in the MCC and also be a serial killer. I think that's the rule. And also, cricket kind of provides him with an alibi. So on the 1st of September, which is the day after Polly Nichols had been murdered, Druitt is down in Dorset playing cricket. And on the 8th of September, which is the day
德鲁伊特的家人怀疑他是开膛手，除了麦克诺顿所说的之外。值得注意的是，即使是麦克诺顿在表达时也显得相当犹豫，所以我几乎可以肯定……我的意思是，你知道，他并没有说他绝对是。另一方面，他是个板球运动员。所以这是一个明确的、非常糟糕的迹象。不，我不这么认为。我不认为你可以既是MCC成员又是连环杀手。我认为这是规则。而且，板球在某种程度上为他提供了不在场证明。所以9月1日，也就是波莉·尼科尔斯被谋杀的第二天，德鲁伊特在多塞特打板球。9月8日，也就是
of Annie Chapman's murder. He is playing for Blackheath in a match that had begun at 1130. So it's conceivable, I suppose, that he could have left Whitechapel and got across the Thames and brush, you know, had a shave and got out his cricket whites and turned up at the ground by 1130. But I don't think that's really adequate preparation for opening the batting. So I don't think what you drew it was it? Okay, fine. So let's turn to the third person that were Norton names. And this is Michael Ostrog. So to Quote's report, Michael Ostrogg, a mad Russian doctor and a convict and unquestionably a homicidal maniac. This man was said to have been habitually cruel to women and for a long time was known
安妮·查普曼被谋杀的那天。他正在为黑希斯队参加一场11点30分开始的比赛。所以，我想可以想象，他可能离开了白教堂，穿过泰晤士河，刮了胡子，拿出他的板球白衣，在11点30分赶到球场。但我认为这对于开场击球来说准备并不充分。所以我不认为那是德鲁伊特，对吧？好吧，没问题。那么让我们转向麦克诺顿提到的第三个人。这就是迈克尔·奥斯特罗格。引用报告的话：迈克尔·奥斯特罗格，一个疯狂的俄国医生，一个罪犯，毫无疑问是一个杀人狂。据说这个人习惯性地残忍对待女性，并且长期以来一直被认为
to have carried about with him surgical knives and other instruments. His antecedents were of the very worst. It's from a poor family. And his whereabouts at the time of the Whitechapel murders could never be satisfactorily accounted. Now, I have to say Michael Ostrogg is an absolutely fascinating and bizarre bloke. I mean, it sounds an old thing to say about a Ripper suspect and also quite a bad man, but he is a tremendous character. So Ostrogg was born in the Russian Empire in the early 1830s and he emigrated at some stage to England, we don't know why. Remember that Mnorton has described him as a mad doctor, cruel to women and a homicidal maniac, and you'll see whether this fits the description that I now make of him.
随身携带手术刀和其他器械。他的前科是最糟糕的。他来自一个贫穷的家庭。他在白教堂谋杀案发生时的行踪从未得到令人满意的解释。现在，我必须说迈克尔·奥斯特罗格是一个绝对迷人且古怪的家伙。我的意思是，对于一个开膛手嫌疑人来说，这听起来很奇怪，而且他也是个相当坏的人，但他是一个了不起的角色。奥斯特罗格于19世纪30年代初出生在俄罗斯帝国，他在某个阶段移民到了英国，我们不知道原因。记住麦克诺顿把他描述为一个疯狂的医生、残忍对待女性的人和杀人狂，你会看到这是否符合我现在对他的描述。
So he first appears in the records in Oxford in 1863 with a series of strange thefts from the chapel, dining hall and student rooms at Oriel and New College. He's been passing himself off for a German student called Max Grief Gossler, and he's stolen some watches, some purses, a handkerchief and somebody's trousers. Right. So this is his first brush with fame. Then he gets into trouble in Bishop Stortford. He has been posing as Count Sobievsky, a Polish nobleman who's escaped from exile in Siberia. And he goes around Bishop Stortford saying to people, I'm this count. or whatever. And to quote from, I think it's from Philip Suggton's book, at the Cochin Horses, Ostrogg dined on the choicest fare the house could provide
他第一次出现在记录中是在1863年的牛津，当时发生了一系列从奥里尔学院和新学院的礼拜堂、餐厅和学生宿舍发生的奇怪盗窃案。他冒充一个叫马克斯·格里夫·戈斯勒的德国学生，偷了一些手表、钱包、手帕和某人的裤子。没错。这就是他第一次出名。然后他在毕晓普斯托特福德惹了麻烦。他一直冒充索别夫斯基伯爵，一个从西伯利亚流放中逃出来的波兰贵族。他到处走，对人们说，我是这位伯爵，等等。引用我想是菲利普·萨格顿书中的话，在“马车与马”旅馆，奥斯特罗格享用了旅馆能提供的最好的食物
and was given the best spare bed. Better yet, the next morning the landlord told him there was nothing to pay and gave him a hearty shake of the hand, leaving in his palm a piece of gold to help him on the road. He does the same trick at Cambridge. He befriends a student, gets money from him. Then he goes to Tunbridge Wells, and at this point he's posing as the son of the king of Poland. He's promoted himself. He gets the band on the parade at Tumbridgewell's to play the Polish national anthem and goes around telling people about all the wrongs that Poles have suffered and all of this kind of thing. Because at this point, Poland doesn't exist, doesn't it?
并被安排在最好的空房间里。更好的是，第二天早上，房东告诉他不用付钱，并用力握了握他的手，在他掌心留下了一枚金币以帮助他上路。他在剑桥也玩了同样的把戏。他结交了一个学生，从他那里骗钱。然后他去了坦布里奇韦尔斯，此时他冒充波兰国王的儿子。他给自己升了级。他让坦布里奇韦尔斯游行乐队演奏波兰国歌，并到处告诉人们波兰人遭受的所有不公等等。因为此时，波兰并不存在，不是吗？
He doesn't exist, exactly. He goes to Woolwich Barracks in 1873. There's he somehow gets into the quarters of Captain F.W. Milner and he steals a soap dish, a shaving pot, a toothbrush dish, and some sort of collar studs worth five pounds. But his finest hour comes at Eton. So Eton again, we've had a bit of Eton, haven't we? Monorton went to Eton, right? Yes.
他不存在，确实。1873年他去了伍尔维奇军营。他在那里不知怎么混进了F.W.米尔纳上尉的宿舍，偷了一个肥皂碟、一个剃须罐、一个牙刷碟和一些价值五英镑的领扣。但他最辉煌的时刻是在伊顿公学。所以又是伊顿，我们已经提到过一点伊顿了，不是吗？麦克诺顿去了伊顿，对吧？是的。
He's got an in for Ostra, Pilfering his old school. Ostroth got into the school and stole a lot of, over a long period of time, over weeks and months, a lot of random things. A silver cup valued at four pounds in the room of Alfred Cook, two silver cups and a coat from the room of John Ellison. One of the school teachers, Mr. Browning, believes his story.
他有奥斯特罗格的把柄，偷窃他的母校。奥斯特罗格进入学校，在很长一段时间里，几周甚至几个月，偷了很多随机的东西。阿尔弗雷德·库克房间里价值四英镑的银杯，约翰·埃里森房间里的两个银杯和一件外套。其中一位老师布朗宁先生相信了他的故事。
about being a Polish count and actually gives him loads of books, a dictionary of biography, a dictionary of geography, a book of Latin quotations, and a book by Darwin. So by the 1870s, 1880s, the law have caught up with Ostrogg. And he's in and out of prison. And he's sometimes in the newspapers. People will say, this bonkers con man has turned up in our town, stealing silver cups and Spanish dictionaries. But there's no record of any violence or anatomical knowledge or wearing deer stalker caps or any of these kind of things. So the business about him being a mad Russian doctor and a homicidal maniac is just not true. It's just not true at all.
关于他是波兰伯爵的故事，甚至给了他很多书，一本传记词典、一本地理词典、一本拉丁语引语集和一本达尔文的书。所以到了19世纪70年代、80年代，法律已经追上了奥斯特罗格。他进进出出监狱。他有时会出现在报纸上。人们会说，这个疯狂的骗子出现在我们镇上，偷银杯和西班牙语词典。但没有任何关于暴力、解剖学知识、戴猎鹿帽或任何这类事情的记录。所以关于他是疯狂俄国医生和杀人狂的事情根本不是真的。根本不是真的。
There was only one incidence of him being violent when he resisted arrest at the Fox and Goose in Burton on Trent. But that is the only time he has in any way behaved anything other. He's basically a, is he a bounder? He's probably not quite. He's a kleptomaniac, surely. He's a kleptomaniac. and a massive bounder who's impersonating, yeah, Tabbis has a blighter. I mean, he's walking up and down, but he's sufficiently suave.
他只有一次暴力行为，是在伯顿特伦特的“狐狸与鹅”酒吧拒捕时。但那是他唯一一次表现出任何其他行为。他基本上是一个……他是个无赖吗？可能还不够。他肯定是个盗窃癖。他是个盗窃癖，也是个冒充他人的大无赖。我的意思是，他走来走去，但他足够圆滑。
You know, he could be played by Peter Bowles or something. He's pretending to be a Polish count and getting able to play the Polish National Anthem. He also wears often clerical garb. Like Calvin Robinson. What he does? Like the self-styled priest Calvin Robinson. So basically, he's a bonkers. person. He ends up being transferred to a lunatic asylum in the 1880s, but a lot of the police
你知道，他可以由彼得·鲍尔斯之类的人来扮演。他假装是波兰伯爵，还能让人演奏波兰国歌。他也经常穿教士服装。就像卡尔文·罗宾逊一样。他做了什么？就像自封的牧师卡尔文·罗宾逊。所以基本上，他是一个疯狂的人。他在19世纪80年代最终被转移到精神病院，但很多警察
said this is a, he's not a lunatic. Like, he's just a bad bloke. He's just a petty criminal. Is he out of the asylum in the summer of 1888? He is out of the asylum in the summer of 1888 in the autumn. So it could be him. And now he was suspected at the time because the police Gazette issued a notice saying this guy is out. He's, he's meant to be reporting to the police on bail, but he hasn't been. Special attention is called. to this dangerous man. And I think this is because they think he's probably not the Ripper, but he could be because he pretends to have medical knowledge, he has a criminal record, and he has a foreign
说这是一个……他不是疯子。他只是个坏家伙。他只是个小罪犯。他在1888年夏天出精神病院了吗？他在1888年夏天，在秋天出院了。所以可能是他。现在他当时被怀疑，因为《警察公报》发布了一则通知，说这家伙出来了。他本应保释向警方报到，但他没有。特别提请注意这个危险的人。我认为这是因为他们认为他可能不是开膛手，但他可能是，因为他假装有医学知识，有犯罪记录，而且有外国背景。
background. However, there are some pretty big obstacles. He's almost six feet tall. Now, at a time when, you know, people are shorter, he stands out. But also, there are so many accounts that say the Ripper is probably 5'4, 5, 5, 4, 6. He's too tall. he is far too old. He's in his mid-fifties, and he has absolutely no record of violence or sexual assault.
然而，有一些相当大的障碍。他身高近六英尺。现在，在人们普遍较矮的时代，他很显眼。但也有很多说法称开膛手可能只有5英尺4英寸到5英尺6英寸。他太高了。他太老了。他五十多岁，而且完全没有暴力或性侵犯的记录。
He's a practiced com man, not a serial killer, and dare I use the expression, the nail in the coffin, in the summer of 1888, a man with the name the Grand Guidon was arrested in France and imprisoned for two years on petty crime and theft. This was an alias that Ostrug had used in France, and it was almost certainly hit. So I think here, McNaughton is indulging himself in, you know, there's a bad, there's obviously the word has gone out to the Old Etonians. This guy Ostrug has made a fool of us. Let's frame him as the Ripper.
他是个老练的骗子，不是连环杀手，而且我敢用这个词吗，棺材上的钉子，1888年夏天，一个名叫“大吉东”的人在法国被捕，因轻罪和盗窃被监禁两年。这是奥斯特罗格在法国使用的一个化名，几乎可以肯定是本人。所以我认为在这里，麦克诺顿是在放纵自己，你知道，有一个坏蛋，显然消息已经传到了老伊顿人那里。这家伙奥斯特罗格把我们当傻子耍了。让我们把他诬陷为开膛手吧。
So I don't think it's Ostrug, but any, I don't think anyone seriously thinks it's Ostrug. Okay, so those five candidates are the ones that we get from police at the time. And listeners can decide how plausible any of those are. Obviously, there have been lots more since, and we'll just look at some of a couple of the more salient ones. And then there's a particular group of suspects as well that we'll end with. So a recently proposed suspects is a guy called James Maybrick, who was a Liverpool cotton merchant who died in mysterious circumstances in May 1889. So again, that sense, perhaps this might be an explanation for why the murders stop. But he actually is the only suspect for the murder so far who actually ends up murder.
所以我认为不是奥斯特罗格，我不认为有人认真地认为是奥斯特罗格。好吧，那五个候选人是当时警方提供的。听众可以决定这些候选人有多可信。显然，此后还有更多，我们只看其中几个比较突出的。然后还有一组特定的嫌疑人，我们将以他们结束。所以最近提出的嫌疑人是一个叫詹姆斯·梅布里克的人，他是一位利物浦棉花商人，于1889年5月在神秘的情况下死亡。所以同样，这种感觉，也许这可以解释为什么谋杀案停止了。但他实际上是目前为止唯一一个最终自己也被谋杀的谋杀案嫌疑人。
murdered himself? Or was he? Because his wife Florence was accused and then convicted of having poisoned him with arsenic. Although in due course in 1904, the case was re-examined and Florence actually ended up being acquitted. But this is obviously the kind of thing that, you know, Victorians love reading about in the newspapers over toast and marmalade, arsenic, suspects, It's, you know, husbands and wives, all that kind of thing. But there doesn't seem anything particularly in that case to link this Liverpool merchant to the murders down in London in Whitechapel, except perhaps the timing of the death. So people may be wondering, well, how on earth did this guy end up becoming a suspect?
他自己被谋杀了？还是说他不是？因为他的妻子弗洛伦斯被指控并随后被判用砷毒死他。尽管在1904年，案件被重新审查，弗洛伦斯实际上最终被无罪释放。但这显然是维多利亚时代的人喜欢在吃吐司和果酱时在报纸上读到的那种事情，砷、嫌疑人，你知道，丈夫和妻子，所有这些事情。但在这个案件中，似乎没有什么特别的联系能把这个利物浦商人与伦敦白教堂的谋杀案联系起来，除了死亡的时间。所以人们可能想知道，这家伙到底是怎么变成嫌疑人的？
And the answer is that in 1992, a diary emerged, and it's an anonymous diary, in which the guy who is writing in the diary claimed to have committed five murders in Winechapel plus two further ones. And although I've said it's anonymous, the circumstantial evidence makes it clear
答案是1992年出现了一本日记，这是一本匿名日记，日记的作者声称在白教堂犯下了五起谋杀案，外加另外两起。虽然我说它是匿名的，但间接证据清楚地表明
that Mabrick is the author or is meant to be thought to be the author. The book in which it's written is authentically Victorian. The ink, it's subjected to scientific tests and it's kind of inconclusive.
梅布里克是作者，或者被认为是作者。书写的书是地道的维多利亚时代的。墨水，它经过了科学测试，结果有点不确定。
In this diary, a reason is given for why Maybrook might be Jack the Ripper and listeners can decide whether they think it's plausible. So in this diary, he's the James Maybrook says that he's seen his wife, Florence, whom he refers to as the bitch or the whore, out with her lover in the Whitechapel district of Liverpool. Of Liverpool? Of Liverpool. And he is so angry and upset about this that he goes. down to the White Chapel in London and murders five prostitutes there. Yeah, that makes sense.
在这本日记中，给出了梅布里克可能是开膛手杰克的原因，听众可以决定他们是否认为这可信。在这本日记中，詹姆斯·梅布里克说他看到他的妻子弗洛伦斯，他称她为“婊子”或“妓女”，和她的情人在利物浦的白教堂区。利物浦的？利物浦的。他对此感到非常愤怒和难过，以至于他去了伦敦的白教堂，在那里谋杀了五名妓女。是的，这说得通。
You know, I leave that for readers to decide. That's a bonkers claim. Now, Dominant, you're sounding sceptical. There is a further piece of evidence in 1993, in rather mysterious circumstances, a pocket watch emerged, genuine Victorian pocket watch. And it was inscribed with the words, I am Jack, comma, J. Maybrick, and the initials of the five victims. Oh, come on. That's laughable. That's, that's, that's,
你知道，我留给读者去决定。那是一个疯狂的说法。现在，多米尼克，你听起来很怀疑。1993年还有进一步的证据，在相当神秘的情况下，出现了一块怀表，真正的维多利亚时代怀表。上面刻着“我是杰克，逗号，J.梅布里克”，以及五名受害者的首字母。哦，得了吧。那太可笑了。那是，那是，那是，
to Jack the Ripper walk around with his name on a pocket watch and the initials of his victims, come on. Well, that's what this pocket watch seems to suggest. Purely, purely because his wife had been carrying on in a district of the same name in a different city. Well, shall we, should we find out how this, how this journal turned up? So when we think the provenance of these important artefacts. Okay, well, it was produced by an unemployed scrap metal dealer in Liverpool who claimed he'd been given it the year before by a mate in a pub. Oh, my God.
开膛手杰克带着写有他名字和受害者首字母的怀表到处走，得了吧。好吧，这块怀表似乎就是这么暗示的。纯粹，纯粹是因为他的妻子在另一个城市的同名地区有外遇。好吧，我们应该查查这本日志是怎么出现的吗？当我们考虑这些重要文物的来源时。好吧，它是由利物浦一个失业的废金属商提供的，他声称这是前一年一个酒吧里的朋友给他的。天哪。
So he then subsequently confessed to having faked it. But he did then retract his confession. A further issue with taking this as something that isn't faked is that all the murders in the diary have clearly been lifted from contemporary press reports. They reproduce all kinds of mistakes and fallacies and errors. And what's amazing is that this is even listed still on, you know, you have lists of suspects and James Mabrook still appears on it. But it's so clearly and palpably a fake. And it's interesting because, of course, what it will probably remind people of if the Hitler Diaries fake, And in a sense, there's clearly a yearning for people to be given the innermost thoughts of people who are seen as the images of absolute evil.
所以他后来承认是伪造的。但他随后撤回了供词。把这当作不是伪造的东西的另一个问题是，日记中的所有谋杀案显然都是从当时的报纸报道中摘录的。它们复制了各种各样的错误、谬误和失误。令人惊奇的是，这甚至仍然被列在，你知道，你有嫌疑人名单，詹姆斯·梅布里克仍然出现在上面。但这显然是伪造的。这很有趣，因为当然，如果希特勒日记是伪造的，这可能会提醒人们。在某种意义上，人们显然渴望被告知那些被视为绝对邪恶化身的人的内心想法。
And I guess that Jack the Ripper and Hitler in that sense are, you know, much of a muchness. But I think it is clearly a fake. So let me mention one other candidate who was brought up after the events. So he was mentioned by a guy called Detective Chief Inspector John Littlechild in a letter to a journalist in 1913. And this is Francis Tumblety. Now, Francis Tumblety, a bit like Ostrug, is a very colourful and shady character. He was probably born in Ireland around 1833. Then his parents moved to Rochester, New York. So he's an Irish-American. As a boy, he's got a very bad reputation. He's clearly a bad sort. He gets into trouble for selling obscene books.
我想开膛手杰克和希特勒在某种意义上是半斤八两。但我认为这显然是伪造的。所以让我提一下另一个在事件发生后被提出来的候选人。他是由一位名叫约翰·利特尔柴尔德的侦探总督察在1913年写给记者的一封信中提到的。这就是弗朗西斯·坦布莱蒂。现在，弗朗西斯·坦布莱蒂，有点像奥斯特罗格，是一个非常丰富多彩且阴暗的角色。他可能于1833年左右出生在爱尔兰。然后他的父母搬到了纽约罗切斯特。所以他是一个爱尔兰裔美国人。作为一个男孩，他名声很差。他显然是个坏家伙。他因销售淫秽书籍而惹上麻烦。
And then according to American newspaper profiles decades later, he then worked for a doctor. who carried on, I quote, a medical business of a disreputable kind. So I'm guessing probably an abortionist. He spends the next few decades as a kind of quack doctor and abortionist across North America, including Canada. So he sells, he's a little bit like Dr. Crippin. He sells kind of mad products that any sane person would surely recognize as ludicrous. So Dr. Morse's Indian root pills or tumbled his pimple destroyer. for example. He goes around, we're in that kind of 1860s, 1870s. He claims to be a former surgeon in the Union Army in the American Civil War. He's arrested for parading in military uniform
然后根据几十年后美国报纸的简介，他后来为一位医生工作，该医生经营着，我引用，“一种名声不佳的医疗业务”。所以我猜可能是堕胎医生。接下来的几十年里，他作为一种江湖医生和堕胎医生在北美，包括加拿大各地活动。所以他卖，他有点像克里彭医生。他卖一些任何理智的人肯定会认为是荒谬的疯狂产品。例如，莫尔斯医生的印度根药丸或坦布莱蒂的祛痘剂。我们是在1860年代、1870年代。他声称自己是美国内战中联邦军队的前外科医生。他因穿着军装游行而被捕
and fake medals. At one point, he's actually arrested in connection with the assassination of Abraham Lincoln. So because he's just such a shady and mad character, and his life is so baroque that I can't possibly summarize it here, if you look at him online, if you look at, for example, his Wikipedia page, you'll see a photograph of him, which gives you a sense of the flavour of the man. He's wearing a kind of Ruritanian military uniform. He's wearing a spiked Prussian helmet. And he has probably the maddest moustache you'll see on, even by rest of history standards. It's a moustache that is, you know, it's far wider than his head. It's probably twice the width of his own head. A moustache that would have been noticed on
和假勋章。有一次，他实际上因与亚伯拉罕·林肯的暗杀有关而被捕。因为他是一个如此阴暗和疯狂的角色，他的生活如此巴洛克，我不可能在这里总结它，如果你在网上看他，如果你看，例如，他的维基百科页面，你会看到他的一张照片，这让你对这个人的风格有所了解。他穿着一种鲁里塔尼亚式的军装。他戴着尖顶的普鲁士头盔。他留着你见过的最疯狂的胡子，即使以历史标准来看也是如此。那胡子，你知道，比他的头宽得多。可能比他自己的头宽两倍。那胡子在白教堂的街上肯定会被注意到。
the streets of Whitechapel. Undoubtedly would have been noticed. However, there are a couple of things that stand out. There's one account of Tumblety by an American journalist Charles Dunham who knew him. And Tumblety said to this guy, I love collecting anatomical organs. And he boasted of having the uteruses of a dozen women in jars. So he collected these things in jars, which is all of its weird and sinister. And he told Dunham that he hated women. He saw them was sinful. He loathed them. The problem with this is that Dunham himself made stuff up. He was As a journalist, he got into trouble for making things up. He had 12 different identities, which is a bit weird.
毫无疑问会被注意到。然而，有几件事很突出。有一份关于坦布莱蒂的记录，来自认识他的美国记者查尔斯·邓纳姆。坦布莱蒂对这家伙说，我喜欢收集解剖器官。他吹嘘自己有装在罐子里的十二个女人的子宫。所以他把这些东西收集在罐子里，这很奇怪且阴险。他告诉邓纳姆他讨厌女人。他认为她们是罪恶的。他厌恶她们。问题在于邓纳姆本人编造了东西。作为一名记者，他因编造事实而惹上麻烦。他有12个不同的身份，这有点奇怪。
And we can't really trust him completely. One other detail, Tumblety was almost certainly gay. We know this because in November 1888, because he would travel between America and Britain, in November 1888, the Met arrested him for indecency, and on the 16th of November, he appeared before the Marlborough Street magistrates and was told he was going to have to appear at the old Bailey. But he broke his bail. He fled to France under a false name. And the American press started reporting that the Met suspected him of being Jack the Ripper. He ended up back in New York. There was talk of him being extradited, but the Metropolitan Pizzily Police did not
我们不能完全信任他。另一个细节，坦布莱蒂几乎肯定是同性恋。我们知道这一点，因为在1888年11月，因为他会在美国和英国之间旅行，1888年11月，伦敦警察厅因猥亵罪逮捕了他，11月16日，他出现在马尔堡街地方法官面前，被告知他必须出现在老贝利法院。但他违反了保释。他以假名逃往法国。美国媒体开始报道伦敦警察厅怀疑他是开膛手杰克。他最终回到了纽约。有传言说他会被引渡，但伦敦警察厅并没有
pursue it. And he died of a heart attack in 1903. So the argument for being the Ripper is as follows. He's a bad man. He's a doctor. Or a quack doctor, anyway. It's possible that he hates women. He probably collects people's organs in jars, which is frankly weird. The argument against he's a bit too tall. He's five foot ten. He's visited Europe and Britain many times, but there's no evidence that is especially familiar with the East End. As you pointed out, Tom, his enormous moustache. Have you seen his moustache online? I have. It's bonkers. He's got a truly massive moustache, especially if he's got that and he's wearing his prussia. and spiked helmets. He's very, very good. Blending in for the elephant man and WG. Grace.
追究。他于1903年死于心脏病。所以他是开膛手的论点如下：他是个坏人。他是个医生。或者至少是个江湖医生。他可能讨厌女人。他可能把人的器官收集在罐子里，这坦率地说很奇怪。反对的论点：他有点太高了。他身高5英尺10英寸。他多次访问欧洲和英国，但没有证据表明他特别熟悉东区。正如你指出的，汤姆，他巨大的胡子。你在网上看过他的胡子吗？我看过。太疯狂了。他留着真正巨大的胡子，特别是如果他留着那个，还戴着他的普鲁士尖顶头盔。他非常、非常擅长融入象人（Elephant Man）和W.G.格雷斯的行列。
He's a bad man, but there's no evidence that he's a madman, a violent man or a murderer, and there is an issue with his sexuality. There are gay serial killers, but they tend to target men, young men. They almost never target women. So it's a struggle. There's a stretch to think that Tumble tea, I think, is the Ripper. Okay, so that's him. eliminated as well. So there's just one final collection of suspects, all of whom have been kind of proposed, I think in kind of recent years. And these are people who either knew or met the murder victims, because it is usually the case, I gather, in investigations into murder, that it turns out to be someone who knew the victim. So Joseph Barnett, Mary Jane Kelly's
他是个坏人，但没有证据表明他是疯子、暴力分子或杀人犯，而且他的性取向也有问题。有同性恋连环杀手，但他们倾向于针对男性，年轻男性。他们几乎从不针对女性。所以这很勉强。我认为坦布莱蒂是开膛手是一个牵强的想法。好吧，他也排除了。所以只剩下最后一组嫌疑人，他们都是在近年来被提出的。这些人要么认识要么见过谋杀受害者，因为我了解到，在谋杀调查中，通常结果是认识受害者的人。所以约瑟夫·巴内特，玛丽·简·凯利的
common law husband, he's been named as a suspect. George Hutchinson, the guy who, met with supposedly the bloke in the Astrakhan coat. Yeah, but he was making that up, surely. Yeah, so Charles Lechmere, who people may have forgotten him, but he is the guy who first came across Polly Nichols' body and was then joined by another person going to work, and they went off and found the policeman and said, oh, there's a body down there. And the possibility of him being the Ripper was first suggested in the year 2000.
同居丈夫，他被列为嫌疑人。乔治·哈钦森，那个据说遇到了穿阿斯特拉罕皮大衣的家伙的人。是的，但他肯定是在编造。是的，所以查尔斯·莱奇米尔，人们可能已经忘记了他，但他就是那个首先发现波莉·尼科尔斯尸体的人，然后被另一个去上班的人加入，他们走开并找到了警察，说，哦，那边有一具尸体。他成为开膛手的可能性最早是在2000年被提出的。
by a riparologist. And then it was a subject of a Channel 5 documentary in 2014. And the circumstantial evidence for that is that. At the inquest, Charles Lechimir gave his name as being Charles Cross. So a different name. Was he perhaps trying to disguise his name? The reason why he would have done that is that his mother had remarried when he was a child to a policeman called Thomas Cross. So presumably, you know, he was known both as Cross and Lechmere.
由一位开膛手研究者提出。然后它在2014年成为第五频道纪录片的主题。间接证据是，在死因裁判官法庭上，查尔斯·莱奇米尔报出的名字是查尔斯·克罗斯。所以是一个不同的名字。他是在试图掩盖自己的名字吗？他之所以那样做，是因为他的母亲在他小时候改嫁给了一个叫托马斯·克罗斯的警察。所以大概，你知道，他既被称为克罗斯又被称为莱奇米尔。
But, you know, I mean, it's a possibility. You could see how, if he was the murderer, one way that he might get rounded, if he was surprised was to say, oh, look, I've just found a body. And it is striking as well that his route to work from Bethnal Green to Covent Garden would have taken him along Hanbury Street, because Hanbury Street leads into the area where Polly Nichols was found, and Hanbury Street is where Annie Chapman is murdered. So it's a possibility, and I think it is interesting that that brings us back to something that we've been mentioning throughout this series, the fact that in Whitechapel, in this period,
但是，你知道，我的意思是，这是一种可能性。你可以看出，如果他是凶手，如果他被惊动了，他可能会说，哦，看，我刚发现一具尸体。同样引人注目的是，他从贝思纳尔格林到科文特花园的上班路线会经过汉伯里街，因为汉伯里街通往发现波莉·尼科尔斯尸体的区域，而汉伯里街也是安妮·查普曼被谋杀的地方。所以这是一种可能性，我认为有趣的是，这让我们回到了我们在本系列中一直提到的事情，即在那个时期的白教堂，
it is taken for granted that people will be going to work or coming back from work throughout the night. And I think that that is a salient fact that does deserve to be born in mind. Yeah. All right. So Tom, I think at the time has come before Tabby and Alia lose the will to live for us to pronounce. So of the suspects we have mentioned, which do you think is the most plausible? Well, I actually think Charles Lechmere.
人们理所当然地认为人们整夜都会去上班或下班。我认为这是一个值得记住的重要事实。是的。好吧。所以汤姆，我想在塔比和阿利亚对我们失去活下去的意志之前，是时候做出结论了。在我们提到的嫌疑人中，你认为哪一个最可信？嗯，我实际上认为是查尔斯·莱奇米尔。
Do you? Yeah. But, I mean, do you have absolutely no evidence? We have positive evidence for basically all the others that they couldn't have done it. Yeah. So going through it all, I think Cosminsky, he's not a violent man. Montague drew it. He surely doesn't know the East End, right?
你觉得吗？是的。但是，我的意思是，你完全没有证据？我们基本上有积极证据证明所有其他人都不可能做到。是的。所以通盘考虑，我认为科斯明斯基，他不是一个暴力的人。蒙塔古·德鲁伊特，他肯定不了解东区，对吧？
And he's playing cricket. I mean, the cricket thing is a bad sign, but I'm prepared to overlook that in this case. Ostrogg, no history of violence at all. Who else who we've got? Jill the Ripper, improbable. Yeah. And George Chapman, or Kwasovsky is he's just another opportunity for me to say a Polish surname. George Chapman, I just don't believe you go from ripping to poisoning.
而且他在打板球。我的意思是，板球的事情是一个坏迹象，但我准备在这种情况下忽略它。奥斯特罗格，根本没有暴力史。我们还有谁？吉尔开膛手，不可能。是的。还有乔治·查普曼，或者克瓦索夫斯基，这只是我再次说出波兰姓氏的机会。乔治·查普曼，我只是不相信你会从开膛手变成投毒者。
I just don't buy that. So actually, of them all, I like Tumblety the best. He collects organs and jars. He's a bad egg. He wears Prussian helmets unnecessarily. You see, all of them are kind of, they're melodramatic. Yeah, of course. I don't think it was Charles Tumblety, but, oh, Francis Tundon.
我只是不买账。所以实际上，在他们所有人中，我最喜欢坦布莱蒂。他把器官收集在罐子里。他是个坏蛋。他无缘无故地戴着普鲁士头盔。你看，他们所有人都有点，他们是情节剧式的。是的，当然。我不认为那是查尔斯·坦布莱蒂，但是，哦，弗朗西斯·坦布莱蒂。
Humblety, by the way. I think it's much like to be someone completely anonymous. Of course. Someone in the East End. And I think that someone like Charles Lechmere or, you know, any of these people who say that they've come across the body or something. I think they are likely. I mean, I don't think it's Charles Lechmere because shall I say now say who I think is the likeliest. Go on. So this relates to where Polly Nichols is found. So people may remember. I said that she's found. by what is now the entrance to a development of the Whitechapel tube station. And the Whitechapel tube station opened in 1876, the East London Railway, and then it was expanded in 1984, when the district railway, now the district line was built, and then the Elizabeth line was built recently. And the Elizabeth line was built over the most notorious Nacca's Yard in the East End.
顺便说一句，是坦布莱蒂。我认为更有可能是完全匿名的人。当然。东区的某个人。我认为像查尔斯·莱奇米尔或者，你知道，任何这些说他们发现了尸体之类的人。我认为他们很有可能。我的意思是，我不认为是查尔斯·莱奇米尔，因为我现在要说我认为最可能的是谁吗？说吧。这与发现波莉·尼科尔斯的地方有关。所以人们可能记得。我说过她被发现了。在现在白教堂地铁站开发项目的入口处。白教堂地铁站于1876年开通，东伦敦铁路，然后于1984年扩建，当时区域铁路，现在的区域线建成，然后最近建成了伊丽莎白线。伊丽莎白线建在东区最臭名昭著的“纳卡场”上。
and this was called Barber's Horse Slaughterhouse and it was on Winthrop Street and Winthrop Street ran parallel to Bucks Row where Polly Nichols was found. So this Knackers yard is between Bucks Row and the railway line and the Underground Station. And it is one of a number of yards that is owned by London's largest purveyor of knackering
这被称为巴伯马匹屠宰场，它位于温思罗普街，温思罗普街与发现波莉·尼科尔斯的巴克斯街平行。所以这个纳卡场就在巴克斯街和铁路线以及地铁站之间。它是伦敦最大的纳卡商拥有的众多场地之一。
So that's the slaughtering of horses. And every day, huge numbers of horses have to be hacked to pieces. And in 1879, a vet noted that one Nacca man told him that he had cut up about 2,000 horses annually. So there's a lot of dismemberment. As a Nacca man, you have to know your way around the body of a horse. And you would become very, very adept at dismembering the bodies of horses. But it's not just about the dismembering of corpse. is because essentially there is no part of a horse that a Nacca's yard doesn't make use of.
所以那是屠宰马匹。每天，大量的马匹必须被砍成碎片。1879年，一位兽医注意到一名纳卡工人告诉他，他每年大约宰杀2000匹马。所以有很多肢解。作为一名纳卡工人，你必须熟悉马的身体。你会变得非常、非常擅长肢解马的尸体。但这不仅仅是关于肢解尸体。因为本质上，纳卡场没有马的任何部分是不利用的。
So you boil the bones down. This draws out the fat, which you can then use as axle grease or to oil harnesses. You can use it actually to oil cricket bats. Until you drew it. Yeah. And then the bones are used to make, I don't know, cutlery or carriage interiors or whatever. And the hooves are used to make glue. And the stench of this is so vile that they can only be boiled during the night.
所以你把骨头煮开。这会提取出脂肪，然后你可以用它作为车轴润滑油或给马具上油。你实际上可以用它给板球拍上油。直到你画出来。是的。然后骨头被用来制造，我不知道，餐具或马车内饰等等。蹄子被用来制造胶水。这种恶臭太难闻了，以至于它们只能在夜间煮沸。
And therefore, because of this, people working in knackers yards have to work around the clock. And so there are shifts and slaughtermen are, you know, a matter of course, you will see them walking through the streets at night, either arriving for a shift or leaving a shift. And we know that there were three slaughtermen who were working at Barber's Horse Slaughterhouse on the night that Polly Nichols body was there. Because we have their names because they went to view her corpse. And these are James Mumford, Henry Tompkins and Charles Breton. And they gave the details of their kind of movements that night at the inquest. And they said that they started work between 8 and 9 p.m. so the previous evening, so that's the Thursday.
因此，正因为如此，在纳卡场工作的人必须全天候工作。所以有轮班，屠夫是，你知道，理所当然的，你会看到他们晚上走在街上，要么去上班，要么下班。我们知道有三名屠夫在波莉·尼科尔斯尸体所在的那个晚上在巴伯马匹屠宰场工作。因为我们有他们的名字，因为他们去看了她的尸体。他们是詹姆斯·芒福德、亨利·汤普金斯和查尔斯·布雷顿。他们在死因裁判官法庭上提供了他们那天晚上活动的细节。他们说他们从晚上8点到9点开始工作，所以是前一天晚上，也就是周四。
They'd finished it at 4.20 a.m. on the Friday morning. So that's around the time that Polly's body is found. And also at midnight, they said that they'd left the slaughterhouse and they'd returned around 1 a.m. and they didn't leave again until they heard about the murder. So what that suggests is that precisely the time when Polly is murdered, a slaughterman, someone who would be absolutely adept at cutting, up a carcass would have been leaving, you know, the yard that is right next to the murder site. If he lives eastwards, he would have gone down Hanbury Street. That would have been
他们在周五早上4点20分结束工作。所以那大约是发现波莉尸体的时间。而且在午夜，他们说他们离开了屠宰场，大约凌晨1点回来，直到听说谋杀案才再次离开。所以这表明，在波莉被谋杀的那个精确时间，一名屠夫，一个绝对擅长切割尸体的人，会离开，你知道，就在谋杀现场旁边的场地。如果他住在东边，他会沿着汉伯里街走。那会是
the route he would have taken. Annie Chapman is the next murder victim. So I think that is entirely possible that someone who is working in that knacker's yard. I mean, there's a reason why he'd be carrying knives. There's a reason why he might have blood. He wouldn't be walking around with his butcher's apron on, but he would, you know, he'd, he'd have a heavy coat on, and that might correspond to the coat that is seen by, by witnesses. And just to say, again, I have no real knowledge of the psychology of serial killers, but two points that is kind of folk wisdom. One is that people in childhood or in their youth display an interest in the torturing of animals, they often go on to become serial killers. And I could imagine,
他会走的路线。安妮·查普曼是下一个谋杀受害者。所以我认为在那个纳卡场工作的人是完全可能的。我的意思是，他随身携带刀具是有原因的。他身上可能有血是有原因的。他不会穿着屠夫围裙走来走去，但他会，你知道，他会穿一件厚外套，这可能与目击者看到的外套相符。再说一次，我确实对连环杀手的心理没有真正的了解，但有两个观点是民间智慧。一个是人们在童年或青年时期表现出对折磨动物的兴趣，他们往往会成为连环杀手。我可以想象，
a case in which, you know, you're a child. The thought of dismembering an animal excites you in some way. And so you find a job in a slaughterhouse. I mean, it would be an obvious career for someone growing up in the East End. So why not? And then perhaps you reach the stage where you think, well, what would it be like to dismember a woman? And the process of murder, as we said, escalates. And the other thing, it comes from a 2009 study by a criminologist called Amy Fitzgerald.
一种情况，你知道，你是个孩子。肢解动物的想法在某种程度上让你兴奋。所以你找了一份屠宰场的工作。我的意思是，对于在东区长大的人来说，这是一个显而易见的职业。所以为什么不呢？然后也许你到了一个阶段，你认为，好吧，肢解一个女人会是什么感觉？谋杀的过程，正如我们所说，升级了。另一件事，它来自犯罪学家艾米·菲茨杰拉德2009年的一项研究。
and she noted that people who work in slaughterhouses relative to workers in other interests have a disproportionate number of arrests for violent crimes and sexual offences. Really? That's an interesting fact. So, you know, I can't give a name. But if I had to name someone I, you know, if I was Inspector Abilene, I would have, I think, interrogated. the workers in that knacker's yard quite intensively. So that's disappointingly similar to my own view. I don't think it was any of the people we've named, just to be clear.
她指出，与从事其他行业的人相比，屠宰场工人的暴力犯罪和性犯罪被捕率不成比例地高。真的吗？这是一个有趣的事实。所以，你知道，我不能说出名字。但如果我必须指名道姓，如果我是阿比林督察，我想我会非常深入地审讯那家屠宰场的工人。所以这和我自己的观点令人失望地相似。顺便说明一下，我不认为是我们提到的任何一个人。
I think it's somebody who will never be known. And to remind people, I think it's somebody who lives in the East End. I think merely being there for a few months is not enough. I think you need to know it. You need to feel confident within that world. I think it is a man in his late between, let's say, 28 and 35 or 40 maybe. I think he definitely has a moustache.
我认为他是一个永远不会被发现身份的人。提醒大家一下，我认为他是一个住在伦敦东区的人。我认为仅仅在那里待上几个月是不够的。我认为你需要了解那个地方。你需要在那样的世界里感到自信。我认为他是一个年龄在28岁到35岁或40岁之间的男性。我认为他肯定留着胡子。
I think he definitely wears a Deer Stalker hat or a cap of some kind. We've mentioned many times Markets, and I think he's a butcher. I don't think he's a doctor or indeed or even a medical student. I think such people would probably stand out. They're too genteel in that world. I don't think this person comes across as mad because there are too many descriptions of them talking, sometimes joking or whatever, with the women before they're killed. So in other words, I think he's perfectly capable of presenting himself as a sane
我认为他肯定戴着猎鹿帽或某种帽子。我们多次提到过市场，我认为他是个屠夫。我不认为他是医生，甚至不是医学生。我认为那样的人可能会很显眼。他们在那个世界里显得太文雅了。我不认为这个人看起来很疯狂，因为有太多关于他在杀人前与女性交谈，有时甚至开玩笑之类的描述。换句话说，我认为他完全有能力表现得像个正常人。
person. And maybe even charming, who knows? Yeah, otherwise, I think would they go with, would they really go with him? You're going to go with somebody who you think is a kind of, at a time when there's a panic about serial killers? Are you really going to go into a yard with the guy you suspect of being a madman? So I think he's a, I think, I did think about a somebody who worked in a slaughterhouse or I thought about a butcher, somebody who's used to wielding a knife and has a degree of anatomical knowledge. But don't forget the doctors were divided about just how precise that knowledge was. So therefore I think probably not a doctor. I don't think he's carrying a black surgeon's bag. I think so much of that is rooted in the political
甚至可能很有魅力，谁知道呢？是的，否则，她们会跟他走吗？在连环杀手引起恐慌的时期，你会跟一个你认为有点不对劲的人走吗？你会真的和一个你怀疑是疯子的人走进院子吗？所以我认为他是一个……我确实考虑过在屠宰场工作的人，或者我想过屠夫，一个习惯挥舞刀具并具备一定解剖学知识的人。但别忘了，医生们对于这种知识的精确程度存在分歧。因此，我认为他可能不是医生。我不认为他提着黑色的外科医生包。我认为这很大程度上植根于19世纪80年代末的政治气候，
climate of the late 1880s, which actually we're the heirs to, this kind of popular sense that it must be somebody from the elite, and it's exposing the deep state and all that kind of thing. And I think that's rubbish. I think, and I think what happened to him, what neither of us had been able to address, of course, is the question of why the murders stop. I think he's perhaps arrested for some other violent crime and was put away. But I think he would then have been noted perhaps by, I mean, I think they would have been looking for people like that. And there is one other thing. I mentioned that Prince Eddie died in the great flu pandemic. That flu pandemic had begun before Prince Eddie died.
而我们实际上是那个时代的继承者，这种大众普遍认为凶手一定是来自精英阶层，是在揭露深层政府等等。我认为那是胡说八道。我认为，我们俩都没能解决的问题当然是为什么谋杀停止了。我认为他可能因为其他暴力犯罪被捕并被关起来了。但我认为他当时可能已经被注意到了，我的意思是，我认为他们当时肯定在寻找这样的人。还有一件事。我提到埃迪王子死于大流感。那场流感大流行在埃迪王子去世前就已经开始了。
So I think it's perfectly possible this is somebody who is killed in what is a colossal pandemic. And the death goes unnoticed and that is the end of Jack the Ripper. And that's why the mystery endures. Yeah, that's a brilliant, brilliant theory. Well, that's it then. We've solved it. Yeah. So the mystery is solved.
所以我认为完全有可能他是在那场巨大的流行病中丧生的人。他的死亡没有引起注意，这就是开膛手杰克的终结。这就是为什么这个谜团一直存在。是的，这是一个非常精彩的理论。好吧，就这样了。我们解决了。是的。所以谜团解决了。
No one ever needs to discuss Chat the Ripper again. And this will come as a great blessing to our long-suffering producers who have now recorded with Theo away, they have presided over the most self-indulgent recording the history of the podcast. I think this is officially the longest ever. So it's not only our producers who are long suffering, so too are our listeners. And if you have made it this far, thank you very much. We will be burying Jack the Ripper and his victims there and we will not be returning to exhume them for a while. For a while? That sounds ominous. Well, never say never. Never say never. But thanks so much for listening.
再也不需要讨论开膛手杰克了。这对我们长期受苦的制作人来说将是一个巨大的福音，在西奥不在的情况下，他们主持了播客历史上最自我放纵的录音。我认为这正式成为有史以来最长的一期。所以不仅我们的制作人长期受苦，我们的听众也是如此。如果你能坚持听到这里，非常感谢。我们将把开膛手杰克和他的受害者埋葬在那里，我们暂时不会回来挖掘他们。暂时？这听起来不祥。好吧，永远别说永远。永远别说永远。但非常感谢你们的收听。
Happy Christmas. Yeah. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
圣诞快乐。好的。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。